I hope you had a good Thanksgiving you
were with your families or loved ones or
at least uh relaxed and enjoyed yourself
over the past week there was a
particularly big news story that's
resulted in a continued news cycle which
is now going on for over a week which is
in many ways unheard of but right now
because Donald Trump went to dinner with
yay and Nick Fuentes among others he is
now being denounced by Mike Pence
several Republican Senators and for
whatever reason this story for for many
reasons I suppose people have made this
story has persisted till today
and we are able to actually sit down
with several of the individuals involved
in that story notably yay Nick Fuentes
and melianopolis of course who made the
dinner happen it's my understanding I
had the dinner invite before I met Milo
okay my bad my bad there you go so uh
we're gonna we're gonna jump right into
it it's just so complicated it
absolutely
so we're gonna we're gonna start with
that and there's a lot we want to talk
about and uh
you know what man this is a this is a
very uh big story a lot of people have
questions about you know what were
Trump's intentions why were certain
people invited and Trump of course has
issued statements so a lot of people
want to know where he stands and more
importantly what happened there and why
and there's also the questions about
what ea24 means and I'll keep that a
little bit vague so they can answer to
that and speak more to that and then of
course we're going to get into a lot of
different issues however head over to
timcast.com and become a member we're
going to have a members only uncensored
show which will probably get a bit more
in-depth on a lot of other issues uh
that I'll just leave it that timcast.com
become a member support our work and
we'll talk about more there smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us as I mentioned is we have yay himself
would you like to introduce yourself
good sir
you did it there you go I think
everybody knows who you are and uh which
of you gentlemen would like to introduce
yourself Nicholas please hi yeah I'm uh
Nick Fuentes first time here on the Tim
cast thank you for having me absolutely
what do you do oh I'm a live streamer I
uh I do a show called America First on
cozy.tv all right and of course Milo you
were here a couple weeks ago yes I'm
your best ever guest
so we've been told that the episode with
you is one of the best podcasts ever
people really enjoyed hearing you speak
I think that's accurate okay yeah well
thanks for coming back thanks I was
wondering how I was going to uh make it
even more extraordinary the second time
I visited but I think I might have
pulled it off
Luke's here total sausage fest tonight
um welcome my name is zuckerdowski of we
are change.org today I'm wearing my
Epstein didn't Epstein himself t-shirt
which you could get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and I think
we should be using that word a little
bit more just like you know this YouTube
channel did an Epstein itself and if
this YouTube channel is epsteined we
will be streaming on Twitter uh so yeah
I started the t-shirt company after
YouTube demonetized me
sothebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
guys buy it that's why I'm here thank
you so much for having me and of course
Serge and I am search.com pleasure guys
all right and I'll just pull up this
story from the hill which is from
earlier today at 5 PM Pence says Trump
should apologize it's wrong to give
anti-semite a seat at the table this of
course is related to a dinner that
happened and I I was wrong a little on
the details so a dinner happened uh Nick
you were there yay you were there I just
want to start off by how did this dinner
come to happen and and what happened
foreign
for about a month we had scheduled the
dinner in October and then he announced
for president he he pushed the dinner
back to November
um
and I've been pulling together a
campaign and after I put up the the
Defcon tweet a bunch of people that have
been canceled like Alex Jones I started
getting contact with other people that
were now on the you know the inside of
the Matrix and uh Alex Jones producer
said that Milo wanted to contact me and
here we are so that's how you guys got
in contact uh yeah originally and um and
then I've suggested uh
um that we bring in uh Nicholas as uh as
a enormous extra brain Firepower that he
is
um his most extraordinarily brilliant
political commentator of his Generation
Um and he's been treated just about as
badly as anybody so I thought he
deserved to be in the room too and um
yeah that's that's pretty much how we
got together
so I have some questions about that but
let's we'll we'll get through the dinner
portion of you know how exactly this
happened what went down so this is how
you get in contact with three of you how
is it that Nick ends up invited to this
dinner
and and what happened
well he he was rolling with me I was
impressed with Nick and I was like
just come to the dinner and we had uh
Karen Giorno pick us up from the airport
and there was a lot of back and forth
there's another gentleman named Jamar
Montgomery that was with us it's a uh
he's an engineer at Boeing and his
was it I'm telling him just uh we should
raise everyone's volume okay cool
um and we sat there and it was like when
Trump came in we were
I said do you want to sit alone he's
like no bring your friends in so a big
thing is like Trump had no idea who Nick
Fuentes was
and but this whole I just I just gotta
go right to the heart of this
anti-semite claim that's happening this
is something if you read the definition
it it says you can't claim that
there's multiple people inside of banks
or in Media
that are all Jewish or you're
anti-semitic and that's the truth
like it's the truth what are we talking
about and what library what do you mean
you mean
I'm saying like I've been labeled
anti-semite right so
there's there's different beliefs about
our our Bloodlines you know like the
documentary that Kyrie posted and in
general America
has been left ignorant and history has
been changed so when we start
questioning things that question the
indoctrination
then you immediately get
you know
um
you said debanked or D what did you say
happened to you or demonetized
de-platformed yeah demonized demonetized
and what's so beautiful about this time
is
everyone got to see
what's really been happening
and now we can really understand we can
see that Ron Emmanuel was right next to
Obama and then Jared Kushner was right
next to Trump
but so so we're getting right into it I
guess right I was I was hoping to go for
the news first before we got into all of
this stuff uh I think I think the issue
is one way to put it is you're
expounding Upon A localization issue
that you've witnessed right let me let
me clarify there are a handful of people
that you see are Jewish in a certain
place and then you associate Judaism
with the power as whereas I view that as
not relevant to it like yeah you're
substantially more powerful than I am
but I don't view what you're doing as an
issue of black people
yeah but have you ever heard the term
the black vote
so it's okay to put us in one net but
it's not okay for me to put them in one
net yeah but I mean that's the basis I
said the hypocrisy that people have been
have been thinking about and knowing
about and realizing for decades we were
all wondering how this dam was going to
break everybody in the country was
wondering why what is the root of this
hypocrisy why can people talk about why
people a certain way why can't they talk
about that group a certain way and uh
the the most the The Wretched and wicked
and oppressive prevailing Orthodoxy of
cancer culture well it turned out that
the one thing that was going to break
the dam was the biggest star in the
world and it took the biggest star in
the world to do it
um and and now the dam is broken so let
me tell you my issue I I don't like
identitarianism you guys are familiar
with what that is well they started it
and they've been visiting on us when I
was asking you about running for uh
president you you immediately said well
you know you'll be good for the black
vote and I said is that because I'm
black no not just because of that so was
that are you doing the same thing I
didn't say that was the only reason I
said it was because as you're personable
to the common person and you probably
would do well with the black vote
absolutely just because I'm black as a
lot of black people don't like me of
course I think uh I think race plays a
role in a lot of things absolutely and I
think that for I think I think the I the
construct of race has really been forced
upon us as just something for us to be
woke about and just constantly talk
about and use it as these like walls
could just say the same thing about
Judaism well let's look at the facts of
what I'm saying though if you say in
this neighborhood where they gerrymander
there's this amount of time so hey I
wasn't doing that it's just
gerrymandering the lawyers and the
Hollywood Executives and the people at
the bank that debanked me and then froze
my accounts you know it's like we want
to jump into protecting the idea that we
can't put a net around something right
but that's been my job as a producer to
take uh you know a Roy air sample and
put a James round drum and put it within
a two two minute three minute song
that's the way I actually think and
that's the way I talk and now this
morning I found out that they were
trying to put me in prison because what
they did was
I moved 140 million dollars into
uh JP Morgan and I said I want to talk
to Jamie Diamond like look at me I'm
just going in naive you know
multi-billionaire like Me Maybe Jamie
Diamond will let me in on some deal flow
wrong and I'm just like I'm banging my
hands like I want to meet with Jamie and
I start complaining online and then they
debank me for complaining and so I'm
about to get debanked they're like you
need to go to Trump's the bank axo
whatever you got to go and I'm like I've
been trying to buy my own bank for the
longest and then we figured out how to
get my own bank it's like 50 million 75
million so I'm about to buy my own bank
but then
as you're about to take the money out
here comes Adidas with a 270 75 million
dollar bill for marketing funds that
they agreed upon because I said to them
hey I'm the marketing give me the
marketing fund which proves by the
response they got when they you know
stole the designs and said we're going
to not call them Yeezys anymore so this
is what I was already fighting Adidas
for so I'm fighting Gap get out of Gap
fighting Adidas and then I deal with
this little bit of noise from you know
Zionism from the fashion world where
they use this plant named Gabby who's
obviously like some kind of CIA agent
knows nothing about fashion this is a
certain thing when someone can't dress
you know that they're not like a fashion
person they're just there as like the
society like the control that they try
to use with celebrities which has now
been broken right because you know where
it broke I know I'm okay I want to get
on like LeBron in a second but I'm going
to come back to this and just talk about
this more morning where uh you know I'm
not going to mention her name because
she's a nice lady but someone at Cohen
resin tells me and I tell my all of my
finance people never use the term a lot
but they said okay you're gonna have to
pay a lot of taxes and that made me feel
like they're just like waiting like we
finally got them we finally can put them
in jail and I was like can I still run
for president in jail I found out I
could so I was like okay that's fine
then
it'll be okay but but if you were if you
were Jeffrey Epstein they wouldn't touch
your bank account they would allow you
to break the rules regulations just like
JP Morgan and Chase did just like
Deutsche Bank did so there is an issue
to bring up with that but when it comes
to the race stuff I think this is an
important discussion to have because I
think I have to I have to complete this
thought you guys got it okay go ahead go
ahead all right because I'm talking
about literally finding out that they
were trying to put me in prison this
morning watch this so this morning yes
so not you know not come to my house
this morning but I found out okay
so they froze they put a 75 million
dollar hold on four of my accounts
and then they said you owe a lot of
taxes took me like six hours to find out
how much a lot was he said well around
50 million dollars now I'm going to
different CFOs like okay so would this
be tax evasion because I'm obviously not
the most financially literate person on
the planet I was just a child basically
like when you become famous you you stop
growing at that point I became famous at
age 24 and I had handlers around I had
my mom around different things and it
was always like you go from one Handler
to the next Handler to the next Handler
so now I'm having I I get to actually
learn how to run a company I get to
learn how to uh you know uh to count
really I had I was like Pablo in a movie
it was like I didn't even know where to
put the money like literally making 300
million dollars cash but you're just
like a high priced you know we're not
going to use the S word just because
it's like too past say to use but it's
like next you know next year I was
supposed to make 500 million dollars in
royalties and like no one needs this
amount of money but when I would work on
homeless shelters and ideas I'd have a
contractor who won't say what race
um
and
the you know they'd be tearing down the
contracts it's all about you know
position it's not about the amount of
money that you have and you know to come
in here I feel like it's a setup to be
like defending I'm not gonna go through
another like I'm literally gonna walk
the F off the show if I'm sitting up
here having a you know talk about you
can't say that it was Jewish people that
did it when every sensible person knows
that I mean Jon Stewart knows what
happened to me and they took it too far
it was like American History X like my
head was on the side of the Curve
and the exact people that I called out
kicked my head we found out that my
trainer was a MK Ultra uh Canadian uh
intelligence he worked in the defense
research and uh development uh in the
Canadian military essentially working on
Scion military this is Harley Pasternak
yeah what I'm saying is look they tried
to medicate me they I was exhausted they
wrongly diagnosed me and they they when
I asked them how much lithium did you
want to put me on exactly it took them
four days to answer because they were
embarrassed about the amount right and I
refused to take this right you
understand that if I had taken the
medication I would not be here and it
would have been woe was he was deeply
troubled we miss him we love his music
though well they would have Britney
Spears to I mean look they would have
Michael Jackson or Worse yeah so I guess
what they did look at what they did to
Brittany when she went in she was tired
she was exhausted she was in a bad way
but 10 years of that medication wrecked
her brain you can see it now you can see
there's not much of her left you
mentioned Pasternak was the name uh yes
Harley pasternack that's the that's the
text message that you posted that we
were talking about here's that's the
lobotomy before the show obviously I'm
getting a bunch of messages from people
people are hitting me up and they're
like you shouldn't host them they're
anti-semitic they're right supremacist
they're racist I do find the idea I do
find it funny or weird whatever that you
know Nick they call you a white
supremacist you're here working with or
for you know one of the most powerful
black men one of the wealthiest and most
famous but uh a lot of people are saying
on the right specifically don't platform
them and I said well I wanna I wanna
understand what they're thinking why
they're thinking it they're part of
they're involved in what may be the
biggest news story of the past week and
we have an opportunity to sit down and
because the red media controls both
sides it just said it as simple as
possible Jared Kushner was an extra Ron
Emmanuel was next to Obama but since
1940 go ahead isn't that an issue of
these individuals like you're you're
extracted I'm not having I'm going to
get I'm going to order with the last of
my money that's available in a different
account I'm going to order a PJ before I
sit and have another Lex Freeman setup
conversation when when I'm literally
trying they're trying to put me in jail
for my opinion but I'm not there I'm not
going to have that opinion I don't care
about people the people those are Bots
that are trying to tell you we realize
look at Pence he's so Trump out you know
I'm saying it's like I would have never
wanted to do anything that hurt Trump
I'm on I'm on Trump's side Trump said
things that hurt me he lied about me but
I mean he's known for lying and when
people used to tell me that you know
he's a liar it's like you know I went
into the trenches for Trump that's
another conversation there was no one in
my position that wore that hat and all
of my surroundings exhausted me it was
like death by a thousand questions I
know I'm jumping to another thing but
what I'm saying is I know you got a rep
for your your people online but it's
like you got a person in real life that
I I'm not with it bro I lost the I I
lost the money for the freedom of speech
and that's what makes me the only
American that we know that really
deserves to run the country because
everyone else your boy DeSantis Trump
whoever they they raising a petri dish
over on the Democrat side is is going to
play the game
here's what I was trying to get to I I
you went right into the anti-semite
thing I think it's something that should
be talked about but if you if you start
bringing this up you're gonna ask my
opinion I'm gonna disagree with you I
didn't ask your opinion on it you don't
jump into it but but I don't care about
your opinion I like your opinion on how
we win an election but I don't care
about anybody's opinion bro I lost they
tried to put me in jail they blocked two
two billion dollars I had like but I
told Farrakhan I said look oh is it
anti-semitismatic for me say his name
out loud like I I administer yeah the
minister like I tell Obama met with them
too oh he was yeah I mean the Jewish
people allowed uh Obama to meet with the
minister you know so uh
Fair can't say what did he have the
money the contract for the next four
years if I hadn't done anything would
have been 500 million dollars a year for
four years what I was fighting for was
the IP so my children could
uh you know uh I'm sorry just sometimes
I think about seven thoughts at one time
because anything I see I come up with
like seven answers to it and then just
choose what it is but but the thing is
when I said my children the reason why
my my brain kind of blocked because it's
like God is saying you know your
children are going to be okay the you
know baby mamas got money right
God is using me he's breaking me down
removing all of the you know richest
person all of this so I can serve him
and the more and more those things are
taken away from me the more I can be
empty and be a vessel and be able to be
used and right now it's like you're not
gonna take if if we can't you're not
going to take my pain away right the
Jewish people say it's the Holocaust
this happened and you can't say anything
about it we can't take their pain away
no one's going to denounce the fact that
they tried to lock me up that's what it
because every time I'm just holding
stride and it's like I didn't I thought
it was more Malcolm X but I find out I'm
more MLK because as I'm getting hosed
down every day by the press and
financially I'm just standing there and
when when I found out that they tried to
put me in jail it was like a dog was
biting my arm and I I I'm I almost shed
a tear almost but I still walked and
stride through it yeah I think I think
they've been extremely unfair to you who
was they though we can't say
because when you think about it consider
it in 2018 what do you mean it's not
what do I mean like uh uh okay so how
about
are you leaving
are you refer to the Press
he's gone
I'll say it right now
um
you got I I you guys want to bring that
stuff up
is going to come in here and say Here's
my opinion here's my suffering I'm gonna
say I hear you and then he's gonna say
and it was Jewish people and I'm gonna
be like okay but don't you consider so
I'm not gonna do this I refuse make sure
he's cool all right go for it Luke and I
love a conversation so uh I can't say
I'm surprised what what what what what
do I even do other than ask him please
elaborate on this are you referring to
individuals are you quite literally
blaming an entire group of people for
the fact that powerful individuals are
causing you harm I I really wanted to
ask Nick about his thoughts about MLK
because I know they contradict uh his
comments about that but but again these
are mass generalizations that don't
really help anyone in my perspective
they just kind of sound like their
opposition they sound what they're kind
of going against the woke mob that's
always saying white men white men are
responsible for everything when I see
people just use generalizations it kind
of cheapens the conversations it
cheapens a dialogue that we could have
here that I was planning to to talk to
yay about specifically they bringing up
like hey let's actually talk about this
in a real concise way let's not get
emotional let's not walk out of here let
me tell all you guys outright I said
this is going to be a big issue
before the show obviously people are
going to bring up the questions of
anti-Semitism why don't we talk about
the news I want to hear what happened
with this meeting I want to understand
what yay 24 is and then we can do a
longer conversation about any of that
stuff and yay literally in the first
five minutes says no I want to talk
about a group of people and and point to
them whatever man this you want to know
why look you know you're not going to
sit here and you're going to walk out of
the room you're free to do so man
but literally I said a couple sentences
about I don't think that's fair did I
did I insult the man he seriously can't
handle he can't handle it he also left
during the Pierce Morgan interview he
did but he came back so I again we
should be able to have this conversation
what's up Chris he lost his phone
look man
I wanted to talk to these guys about why
they're meeting with Trump I want to
know what happened with the dinner
because we hear a lot of rumors about it
I want to hear about their 2024 platform
which they were promising which they
were talking about like they're going to
be officially let me let me explain to
everybody you know unfortunate they
walked out fine maybe they'll come back
whatever
this is the biggest challenge with
dealing with identitarianism
I do not believe that the predetermined
factor in someone's worth value or
agenda is based on immutable
characteristics uh Kanye is a black man
he does not represent all black people
there are Jewish individuals who work in
in Banks Dave Chappelle made the joke
about Jewish people in Hollywood and he
said it doesn't mean anything you got a
lot of black people in Ferguson doesn't
mean they run the place the point is me
I'm all about individualism meritocracy
personal responsibility that means an
individual of any background can be
capable of anything more importantly we
have employees here who are Jewish who
spend time in Israel and would probably
agree with a lot of issues that they
would talk about especially as it
pertains to America first you know
bringing jobs back here and securing our
borders but then it's just like every
step of the way it's like bro if you
live in a world where a single group of
people is is haunting you you've lost
you you're you're trapped you're not
going to get out the issue is you can
overcome anything I understand you know
and and I empathize that there are
powerful business interests that are
coming coming Kanye and I will say this
because I wanted to get into the Trump
stuff
when when Kanye mentioned he got
suspended on Twitter
then he gets word that Milo wants to
meet up with him then Milo puts him in
touch with Fuentes my immediate you know
my question is okay my thoughts of
myself
we really want to know about the inner
details of this Trump meeting
I guess it's not going to happen my
question then is don't you think that
you know if if Kanye is going to say
these things and then immediately start
getting involved with Fuentes that only
amplifies the accusations made against
them
but I guess if they genuinely believe
these things that's who they are I was
dying to interrupt I was dying to say a
whole bunch of stuff during his you know
his conversation I respectively you know
didn't I was waiting to counter back but
we didn't even push back at all we
didn't even really say anything uh I'm
crazy out there I mean that come on like
we we should at least have the tough
conversations we should debate what are
these ideas what does he think is going
on and I I don't know but I wish I just
wish people were again like hey you
don't agree with me 100 that's fine
that's okay I'm not gonna run away like
like come on let's let's have this
discussion I don't know conversation I
really wanted to talk about Balenciaga I
really wanted to talk about Harley
pasternik I really wanted to talk about
Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle talked
about you know a lot of the things that
that yay was warning about specifically
with people trying to drug him
specifically with people trying to of
course get him on big Pharma medicines
he was again sent to you know he was
institutionalized a couple years ago
specifically on November 21st 2016 he's
pointing a lot of this blame on on this
Harley Pasternak guy who uh again he's
the one who's training lizzo Elliott
page he was training Brittany Murphy he
trained a lot of controversial figures
and he is connected to a Canadian
military psyops that's like we should
know what else is happening behind the
scenes there what else he knows but
before the show we can't even get that
before the show yay was like this was
funny you know he's like how do I become
president how do you win and I thought
it was a rhetorical question because
like why would I know that question and
he was like hey man I asked you a
question you know what do you think and
I was like oh yeah ballot harvesting
like hands down you go to door-to-door
he but he brought it up when he
mentioned that I said that he would do
well with the black vote I feel like
it's kind of oversimplifying what I said
um what I said was that he's a he's a
celebrity he's a personable character
he's he he appeals to regular people
more so if he knocked on the door and
you said Trump Biden yay they'd be like
yay you know but I but I do think that
he would do uh I I do think he would do
better with with the black vote simply
because there's people who look up to
him because they see they can see
themselves in him now let me let me let
me elaborate that's actually more of a
leftist position this woke position uh
because I don't completely disagree with
every every uh component of what
diversity is I think that it's true that
if you're a little kid growing up in
this country
and you're not white but all you ever
see on billboards and all you ever see
in TV is white people that that means
something that has an effect on you and
that's basically what I'm getting to all
I can really say is this uh bro if if I
can't ask you questions
call me like hey but don't you think
this is like localizing he could have
been like I don't you know I I genuinely
view it this way and I'd have said well
okay I can only ask you the question
you're allowed to believe what you want
to believe
but dude like what did I ask him like
three questions about it and he just got
up and left like he's gonna come here
and just talk and be an uninterrupted
before we started the show he said hey
we're doing this show why don't we do it
every week and I'm like what is this is
this is what is because you can't get
enough on any other shows I'm sorry bro
this is not a show where you come in and
talk by yourself and say whatever you
want and say things that are uh that
that that warrant questioning at the
very least at least for clarification
yeah I mean that question everything
should be uh debated everything should
be you know talked about we shouldn't
stray away from uncomfortable situations
we we decide to take things head on like
we have our particular viewpoints they
have theirs we it's obviously there's a
difference obviously we believe in
different things let's see which idea is
better let's see which idea wins out in
the public sphere let's actually have
that conversation and it's kind of sad
that we can't well I think it's funny
that like we got people in super chats
who are like why didn't you just let
them keep talking can keep talking but
that's not how the show works we cut
each other off all the time I just cut
you off right now I know right this is
this is this is our this is the way we
do this guys I'm sorry man I'm not here
to do a show where we let one like look
we and Milo come on a couple weeks ago
and he mostly just talked and I think
there's there's something interesting
there Milo had been banned for a really
long time and had hadn't spoken out in
years five years yeah he's been on a
whole bunch of podcasts so when we were
talking about bringing them on I said
look man
after after the Kyle Rittenhouse stuff
people were like are you gonna get him
on the show and I'm like I don't want to
chase after a dude who like he's in the
news yeah he goes on Rogan before he
goes on Friedman and then I'm like
that's cool they got those conversations
then we were told we would get Milo
Fuentes and yeah at the same time and we
could talk about this big news because
that's what we do we are a topical news
show with guests we are not Joe Rogan
Experience we're not guest interviews
and so with Milo we had him on and it
turned into something different because
the man's been out of the Limelight for
five years and came back and said Trump
supporters want revenge
so here on this show I don't want to
tell you man yay doesn't have to do
anything he owes me no no favors he
wanted to come on the show but he didn't
want to have a conversation yeah I
didn't disrespect him we were nice to
him you know we we hung out with him uh
uh before the show you know we we tried
to accommodate him the best of our
abilities but he didn't want to
entertain a conversation I can't make
him he doesn't owe me that he can leave
that's his that's his thing you know
appreciate him him trying as best as he
did that's about it that's true I mean
what else can you do right I mean look
you know let me tell you guys some
stories because uh I guess this is the
show now welcome to the Monday night
show it was all hype and then all
nothing
you know I don't like identitarianism I
I've never been a fan of people who've
blamed everyone else for their problems
I remember doing Occupy Wall Street you
had people saying it was the one percent
that was the cause of their problems and
I'm like what are you talking about you
got one percenters here giving you money
you've got rich people down here
supporting Occupy Wall Street providing
funding you've got like George Soros
money going into these non-profits that
are funding you to complain about rich
people it that the problem is is varying
agendas the problem is varying
ideologies the problem is everyone
fighting for power for what they want
in yay's circumstance they're coming
after and they're trying to take away
his stuff they're threatening them with
institutionalization and I understand
all of that it's unfortunate that he's
he's internalized this problem to it is
a it is a specific ethnic and religious
background that's doing it and I'm like
bro it's specific people doing it to you
you know what I mean yeah I don't know
what else to say we can read super chats
well I think Super chats would be
interesting to to spur on this
conversation but we made it 27 minutes
and YouTube didn't take it down yay just
got up in line yeah people people don't
understand we took a big risk tonight
like it was my channel it was your
channel especially on the line because
again we're we're hosting conversations
that are tough that are not easy to have
that we need to be ready for that we
need to of course counter ideas just to
let the best idea win so you know it
would take in this risk it's just
unfortunate that it play it played off
the way it did again we don't he doesn't
owe us anything uh but it it this just
should have done I I just wish it would
have went a totally different way but
you can't control individuals and if
someone can't handle getting their their
assertions questioned well why did he
get so angry about it I don't get it I
don't understand it it's not like we
were confrontational it's not like we
were rude uh I definitely I I definitely
disagreed with some of the statements
and I was waiting to jump in just to
have that conversation well here's my
thing I don't know who he's talking
about I don't know exactly what happened
yeah and so when he says a thing
happened to me and I'm like but who did
it
what am I supposed to be like you've
gotta I'm sorry man like the idea that
you've got a group of people
of this like
it just doesn't make sense I'm sorry man
it just doesn't there's there's
certainly powerful individuals who are
friends with each other like I said
Bezos billionaire Bill Gates billionaire
Bill Gates going on TED Talks talking
about depopulation you've got uh here's
an example Shane Smith CEO of ice Irish
Canadian Guy multi-billionaire created a
woke media Empire so when we're talking
about censorship and silencing and he
says it's like Jewish or whatever and
I'm like
but you what do you what does that mean
like there's woke entities that are
completely white European dudes anti-fas
mostly white European they're not Jewish
guys going around smashing up Windows
this is this is the issue of people
blaming a group of people when the issue
is specific to
something unrelated to their background
I don't know what else man how are you
guys doing um I don't know I might want
to go downstairs and see if we could get
him back I think it's worth a try
I'm gonna try to talk to him see if we
I'll read super chats yeah I'll read
super chats and uh
well that was fun
we're just gonna sit here I guess so
we'll rate some super chats because uh
otherwise that's it
you know it is what it is guys we try we
try I mean Luke is right he has left
podcast before and then come back
sometimes it just takes people and it's
a really good lesson it takes a minute
to calm down then you can come back
after he needs to explain what he means
right he can't just say it's true and
I'm like what do you mean by The Who you
referring to no I'm done I'm gonna leave
him it's like okay then I assume you
have nothing behind what you're saying
right and here and I'll tell you what
else too because when early on he said
like how do I want to set ballot
harvesting but I gotta say man if if
this like why would someone vote for
this right that's what's already been
mentioned in the super chats as well
yeah yeah someone actually said why
would I vote for a guy who's you know
going to act this way or like trust
nuclear codes or something I don't I
haven't wrote it actually
hey
go over there this is cool so uh it's
yay it's yay oh sorry oh my gosh did I
just dead name Mary's here that's rough
man so what happened tell me what's
going on outside
um so Kanye and Milo yeah
he is gonna beat me up
um so Milo and Nick and yeah they all
just got a card they cut a card they're
heading out but they don't seem angry
but they just uh Connie specifically
said that he felt as though he should
have been able to keep talking he feels
like not enough people are expressing
this View and he felt like sorry I just
ran upstairs I can't talk perhaps
cutting him off was uh not a good move
so Milo felt like you were obstinately
not getting the point that everyone in
the room was getting they weren't
explaining it I think that they should
have stayed to explain it
before the show when I said guys I
understand you want to talk about that
we have an opportunity to discuss this
big news is can we talk about the news
before we and then we'll we'll focus on
what yay 24 is and what you want to do
but I think this is the problem with
grievance uh um politics instead of
being like here's my plan for America
it's they're the problem they're the
ones doing this who how dare you bro
tell me what your plan is tell me what
you want to accomplish tell me tell me
exactly what your plan is other than
they're harming me and they're bad
people and I refuse to sit and listen to
anyone who would say otherwise yeah I
think one of the major challenges about
Tim cast as a format show is that it's
not an interview it's a thing that I
love about this program which is like
you may be an expert in something but
what we really want is for you to come
here and talk about the news with us
talk about current events discuss and
while you know I think we're all really
excited to hear more about like all
three of these people's perspective on
stuff like it's hard you can't help it
to yeah it's not a monologue so it's not
it's not it's not that it's like hey
guys can we talk about the news before
getting into how you feel behind it yeah
I I just really get into the dinner
because he jumps immediately into he
wants to talk about Jews and I'm like
are you kidding dude and I said you want
to go right into that fine whatever so
be it yeah but if dude can't handle a
conversation about it it's it's insane
to me
he found out they want to put him in
jail but what exactly does that mean
well it sounds like what he was saying
was he found out this morning that
they're saying he owes tax he owes taxes
and then if he doesn't pay him they're
going to lock him up or something
and the thing that he walked out on was
you asked him to clarify who he meant by
they specifically that's pretty all
right because I said you were saying
they as in the corporate media
the same way that you mean it and then
and then he got up and stormed out
that's basically that's crazy I really
that's a shame like I wish that you guys
had gotten to have the conversation you
wanted to have yeah you don't have it I
feel bad for the audience honestly
because I feel like that could have been
a really interesting conversation and
now we're in a position where I am yay
and you know that was sitting here I
don't remember who was sitting in my
seat Nick Fuentes I'm Nick Fuentes yes
don't we look great uh no I would I I
mean what do you think's gonna happen
does like here you know you didn't say
that he would be back tonight
no he's not back tonight maybe he'll
come back maybe no future at some end
yeah I doubt it dude I mean look man
people how did pre-show go like what did
you guys what was the vibe in here
beforehand it was fine it was good and
and and uh we should have just filmed
the pre-show because they didn't even
talk about this [ __ ] no I'm swearing
they were we were talking about like it
was it was it was religious philosophy
plans for the future and I was like this
is really interesting stuff I know they
have these views I I obviously and
people are texting me about it and I'm
like okay here's here's here's what we
do
there they they had look all they did
was remove themselves from the
conversation they had an opportunity to
explain what was going on and why and
all that happened is it seemed like Yay
came in here and just went for every
possible way to make himself look worse
so what was like your your winning
question for this like you knew they
would probably bring this stuff up you
knew identity politics are different but
that's why I was like I want to know
what happened like even before they got
here I was like guys we want to know
about the dinner like I'm hearing a lot
of rumors I'm hearing that you know what
was it like Yay asked Trump to be his VP
or something
why was why was funnest at the dinner
with Trump what did Trump say
was it is this true Trump didn't know he
was well he said Trump didn't know who
Fuentes was that's what I want to
understand what is Trump doing why is
everybody denouncing Trump right now is
this a legitimate criticism of trump
apparently now it is
apparently absolutely the report that
Trump began deriding Kim Kardashian and
during that dinner seemed very strange I
have no idea why he would do that I feel
like there's no way to know about this
dinner without the three people who just
left this room which is uh unfortunate
because that kind of dinner can affect
so many people right there are Americans
across the country who will be affected
by the conversations they had I would
have loved to see the transparency and
kind of know what's going on uh and it's
unfortunate that we couldn't progress
further in that conversation whether or
not you know we all would have seen eye
to eye during it I can't believe he got
so mad so quick
he didn't really seem mad when he was
down there he just seemed uncomfortable
I don't know it's so weird I just feel
like he's someone who has values and it
seemed like he felt like he wasn't you
know I know he and Luke had sort of come
back forth he said you gotta let me
finish my thought maybe he felt like
this uh conversation was
sort of being structured in a way that
wasn't letting him Express himself well
I feel mad that he's used to which is
like one-on-one that's what I mean by
like you I think people aren't always
ready to come onto the show because you
are responding to current events you are
not uh being interviewed in a
traditional way people don't get this
too because uh we had um we've had
people on the show
who end up not talking about their their
their Specialties or anything like that
so like someone might do a show on video
games and then come on the show and talk
politics right and it's like right
because that's what we do so for example
uh shout out to our good friend Blair
white Blair white pointed out that um on
the last show we did she was like
actually every time you've had me on
we've never talked about trans stuff and
I was like yeah we talked we talk
current events and politics and you're
an individual who has opinions on it
that's what we do I just talked to them
outside they're in the car and I'm like
they're leaving I'm like let's let's let
the best idea win you don't owe us
anything let's have this conversation
and essentially he said you know
you don't believe in my truths
like this is my truth you guys are
denying it and I don't want to have this
conversation that sounds like leftist
BS and I'm like look I disagree with you
like and that's okay
knowing you and if you think you're
right explain it to us that's what I
said I was just running up that's what
I'm like disappointed by I wanted to
hear more from each person at the table
about just what they're doing and what
their vision is because even if you
don't agree with them they're really
interesting and they are doing some
really big things did he make any
suggestion at all that he would come
back at some point no he's like I don't
want to have a conversation with you
guys because you guys you know
essentially doesn't see the bigger truth
of what he is his or I'm like those are
your truths
the defender side and let the best idea
when let's at least continue the
dialogue and conversation because people
are going to look at you right now and
they're going to say you can't have a
debate you can't even have conversation
that's what I told him Nick or Milo say
anything back they're just kind of
snickering laughing in the back it's
like
I'm like we had this big opportunity
right here to have this discussion to to
debate it to to talk about it and
they're just like no no it's not going
to work that's all right you know it's
it is it is what we complain about with
wokeness and grievance politics he was
like I just want to work he told me he
wants to work with me on on food uh and
I'm like oh yeah literally he's like
he's like hey man can you I really I
really want to work with you on the food
uh but with this stuff like I'm just I'm
just done I don't wanna I don't want to
have this conversation I feel like it's
hard it's like I I want to know what
this conversation is I feel like without
it like it's all speculation and it's a
real missed opportunity I think for
everyone involved here like even if you
feel like you're gonna butt heads we've
had guests on who are uh definitely
opposed to both of you at the table who
are definitely willing to push back on
the things you're saying and like it
makes the show better I think it's
better for everyone
when you have tension in the room to a
certain degree
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Nick and Milo
set up yay
set him up for what exactly
before the show started I was calling
Milo Lord Varys uh and he was screaming
don't call me now stop it I don't like
okay Lord Varys and uh there's an aspect
of this that I think is worth kind of
considering when it comes to the kind of
setting up the the kind of larger things
happening behind the scenes here that I
think is worth thinking about that you
know we we sadly don't get a preview
into well I had a bunch of questions
right so uh we'll talk about those
questions I'll answer them on Kanye's
behalf no I think I I uh I think Milo is
a genius just because but you know miles
a very very smart guy and he's extremely
funny and he's very very witty and I
think the most
the stupidest thing The Establishment
did was cancel him the stupidest thing
Republicans do is cancel them because
this is Milo's Revenge Milo said on the
show last time it was here that Trump
supporters wanted revenge and now the
narrative going around is that what's
happened with Nick Fuentes at Trump's
dinner and with yay is Revenge on Trump
because Trump's reeling from this so uh
you know what I'll do let me let me let
me let's let's pull this up take a look
at this tweet we'll get it we'll get
some segments out of this
he's a what is it senior politics
reporter Huffington Post you know we
love Huffington Post he says GOP Senator
thunan Trump has dinner that's just a
that's just a bad idea on every level
then he's got what is it Frank Thorpe we
cannot tolerate anti-Semitism it's bad
says corn and blunt I've been uh tired
about responding about what president
Trump did uh I wouldn't want to have
dinner without those guys Ernst I think
it's ridiculous the point is every
single Republican is now coming after
Trump over having done this and uh
Milo's the one who connected it so I I'd
love to ask Milo you said years ago that
you wanted revenge over over the
treatment that you received after being
canceled is this it
he's such an interesting figure for a
lot of reasons but it's hard not to
think in the years that they canceled
him sent him back he just sort of became
more powerful and is now acting on some
sort of master plan I mean this
Candace Kanye's potential run for
president is disruptive to the party it
is the same way that any Third Party
candidate entering a race can siphon off
votes we don't know what will happen if
he becomes a stronger and stronger
variable in this kind of dynamic I mean
I know we speculated about if Kanye
moves forward what happens with the
santis like
they really do control a lot of the
narrative right now and I think a lot of
that is to Milo's credit I think I think
to respond to my uh good conservative
friends who are messaging me like Tim
don't have these people on they're bad
people no no I think you should all
invite them on because I think if
anything is bad for their ideas it's
exactly what just happened yeah and and
yeah when he first came here it was
sincerely asking like Hey how do I
become president of the United States
I'm like
we're not politicians we're we're not
you know advisors here but but you know
we gave him some answers but he he was
asking that question a lot it does seem
like it's something that he seriously
wants to uh you know do talking to Milo
Milo was like you know we we can't say
certain things because of the FCC uh but
you know this is what we're you know
kind of essentially how is it look at
that we basically had an hour
conversation in this room the pre-show
as we're getting camera and lighting
corrected and had nothing to do with any
of that stuff right talking about
religion talking about philosophy
talking about you know what what it
means for a potential campaign if they
have one and I'm like this is cool stuff
this is going to be a good conversation
and then the first thing in five minutes
he's like I want to talk about Jews I
mean do you think it's like the first
thing out the bat I'm like come on was
it on purpose do you think it's that
some people come into interviews knowing
like they're gonna they're gonna ask me
about this they're gonna because I'm
sure Kanye or yay I'm so bad at this
um but I'm sure a lot of people go into
interviews especially when you're that
big a figure with a Target on your back
thinking like some journalists is going
to sit here and get me comfortable and
then hit me with one of these questions
that makes me look bad I think in some
ways it must be at the Forefront of your
mind going into interview like this is
the topic that everyone actually wants
me to talk about I don't even think you
were going to ask about it I didn't
think you were either about what stuff
about his views on Jewish power I I
we're gonna mainly ask about the
candidacy I want to talk about topicals
yeah yeah so like I had a bunch of
people say to me Tim you need to
denounce them right off the bat and I
was like oh that's so tired like bro
anybody who watches my show and who's
honest knows that I don't I don't care
for identitarianism racism anti-semitism
but Kanye West is one of the most
influential guys on the planet he's got
people who genuinely love and respect
him and he's got a bunch of ideas
pertaining to what it means to run for
president what he wants to do and why he
thinks he's the best so I'm going to
talk to him about that and then I said
even before the show is like who are we
kidding guys we I know this is going to
come up but you know we'll we'll talk
about it and they're like we got it we
get it well I think they never even
signed the portraits I think it's kind
of like when um they're skipping
protocol uh no it reminds me of uh the
times that we've had Marjorie Taylor
green on right some people look here
that you're having her on and say you
you can't do that she's controversial
she does bad things I don't like her and
ultimately especially if you have some
kind of tension against someone hearing
them out and getting their perspective
is the best way to form your opinion
accurately and often especially if known
with Martha Taylor crane we've had
people be like I just sort of wrote you
off because of all the headlines about
you but getting to hear your side and
getting to your perspective has really
altered my view maybe it doesn't make
you a fan maybe it does make you this is
hold on like all the media that are like
D platform D platform it's like was that
not a good display of the depth of their
ideology
none on unable to withstand five minutes
of questions I wasn't mean I did not
insult him we talked beforehand and I
was like what do you mean by that I
don't you know I said I don't use the
word they the way you mean I'm talking
about like and it just gets up and walks
out yeah like he doesn't want to hear
what I have to say about my ideas but I
have to sit here and listen to him you
know you know what I think man there's a
reason why yay is who he is they say
that celebrities
all of them tend to have some some
degree of narcissism they feel that they
should be seen by everybody and thus
they end up putting themselves out more
which increases the likelihood of Fame
and notoriety Yours Truly included I
don't think I'm exempt for any of this
stuff I'm sitting here pointing a camera
in my face talking to it all the time
and I talk a whole lot
but I think yay is a guy who has has
risen to this position because he's
assertive and because he's willing to do
something like that right imagine you're
talking to a guy who's got a billion
dollar shoe Empire and you know that if
you say the wrong thing he's out and
you've lost everything yeah he owns the
conversation he does
so that so that works for him in
business does not work for them in
politics yeah you're not going to get a
single vote if you're sort of storm out
not not do anything for anybody you know
there's a lot of things to to kind of
break down and talk about here I have my
own theories and assertions and if you
guys don't go along with it I'm like
yeah that's totally cool that's totally
fine it's not the end of the day but I I
think it's also fair to say that he's
going through a tremendous amount of of
pressure a lot of stress and I I think
when he was you know institutionalized
and drugged in 2016 I think there might
be still you know I I again I don't know
here I'm speculating maybe some larger
effects here maybe he still hasn't
recovered from that you know ssris and
was it lithium that he was talking about
you know those drugs have have a severe
effect on you and could affect your
decision making
um so yeah well I don't I don't want to
discredit him with that like the mental
health stuff because a lot of people
have said that I think it's worth
discussing you can't listen to anything
yay says because he he's mentally ill or
he's off his meds all of that stuff is
just ad hominem I think you know yeah
I'm not saying 25 year old man he has
he's extremely influential powerful he
can make his own decisions and I think
that he made the wrong one tonight by
walking out absolutely I'm just I'm just
saying that this deserves also it's
really weird Tim today New York you guys
are here too well don't look at me it's
weird for all of us we kind of I really
wish that they had signed the portraits
it really hurts me my perfectionist
brain well what can you do but but it's
not that they were off demented that
they were forcefully put on the meds and
when you look at a lot of people that
are forcefully drugged you do see a lot
of long-term negative consequences and
actions again I'm not trying to excuse
anything but I think it's worth a
discussion uh especially when it comes
to this Harley pasternack uh individual
uh the larger effects of this the
threats that were being made against
them the pressure he talked about uh you
know going through a particular
difficult before the show began a
difficult situation with the divorce and
custody with children so again
tremendous amount of pressure and stress
no excuses for anything hey let's debate
these conversations let the let's debate
these ideas clearly that didn't happen
clearly it wasn't ready uh some people
are saying the whole thing was planned
you're I feel like him walking out
already you wanted him to walk out did
they have a car ready no they were in
the truck they were waiting no they
didn't have a car ready I mean I
honestly you know as much as I I want
this conversation I want it for the
company and I want it for the audience
like I have a a piece of like I have
some respect for someone who's like look
I'm done like I think so often we are in
a culture that demands people continue
to talk all the time and if you don't
want to you don't have to I am just sad
that we didn't get to hear what happened
at Mar-A-Lago I am sad that we didn't
get to hear more of these perspectives
because this is such an interesting
interesting Trio of people and it was
worth hearing it is worth knowing
because all we can do now is speculate
imagine sitting down with Trump too
right Trump I I don't she's walked out
on some but I don't think he would walk
out like that yeah I want to hear his
version of events yeah because Trump you
got to come on now because there's also
a lot of other reports saying that he
was screaming at that particular dinner
with Nick there that there was a big
argument that there was yelling that was
the point of bringing these guys on yeah
not to like have him opine on his
thoughts about an entire body of people
that everyone's already heard before
that's the crazy thing he he like
likened this to a Lex Friedman interview
yeah it's like bro we're not here to
talk to about that we're here to talk to
you about your plans man yeah I told
them this before the show and I say this
you know I don't think I don't think
yeah he's crazy some people are like
maybe he's bipolar it's like dude we
were talking to him before the show he
was of complete sound mind he's just
emotional like would you do something
different like you let off tonight with
story about Mar-A-Lago would you have
led off with something else I'm just
curious because then you're introducing
our format this is why I think you know
someone super chatted saying they think
that this thing was staged a publicity
stunt because walking out generates more
press because it gives something it
gives the press something to write about
if they didn't storm off the press would
have been like here are a few things
they said but by storming off now
there's a story about yay just throwing
up and leaving and that generates press
so it's like but it's not positive press
if you're looking for political
credibility I think that part of the
reason he walked out and he's this uh
emotionally
uh stressed out right now is because he
has the soul of of an artist and not of
a politician and that's usually a good
thing actually well if we you know if
there's one thing we know from Milo he
understands he understands that any
press is good press and he kind of
utilizes that to his personal benefit I
don't know maybe he thought if there was
a debate maybe you know things wouldn't
have not looked as as as good here and I
don't know I don't think I mean I think
we knew going in that we were going to
have five enormous Personalities in this
room Serge I'm sorry about that one
buddy but you're much more low-key and
that thanks anyone was bound to become
more tense it's just it was a question
of how this Dynamic would play out and
I'm again sorry that it played out this
way because it leaves so many questions
on the table I just don't want to
speculate about mental health through
the effect of pills or I don't believe
this was staged but like whatever
happened I just think that it would have
been an interesting conversation do you
think you want to ask him to come back
at some point in the Future No not
tonight but I'm not gonna ask him to
come back dude he doesn't owe me
anything he doesn't have to sit on my
show he can leave whenever he wants so
here let me let's be candid
before the show I get a bunch of people
saying like are you crazy don't the
conservatives don't host these people
they're trolls their Edison how how
could you platform them there's
Republicans saying like we don't believe
in platforming these people and I'm like
oh okay like when antifa shut up to Ann
coulter's thing I get it that was more
violent but dude don't tell me about
de-platforming people that are in the
news on a big story because that means
nothing to me why are they there why are
they meeting with Trump I want to know
and if you don't want to know that's on
you but I don't I don't take this whole
Deep platforming thing that being said
right now you've got people saying Tim
you screwed up it's your fault then I've
got people saying wow he's a crybaby
I've got people saying you are you
handed it Mass really masterfully I got
people saying like you did you did a
miserable job why didn't you you played
it wrong I don't care guys there's
nothing I can do I am who I am before
the show people were like have you been
preparing if you're doing research and
I'm like what does that mean like all I
know is I told them what the show is I
told them what the plan is I said if you
want to talk about that stuff we should
probably save it closer to the end
because we want to talk about the news
that's what we do on the show you didn't
want to do it he doesn't have to do it
he doesn't owe me anything he's a rich
guy he can do whatever he wants he got
up and he left so be it
yeah that's what it is so your
uh
ultimate goal for this conversation was
to talk about Mar-A-Lago did you feel
like at any point today you got any
information or any insight into how that
dinner went well we know uh yay said
Trump didn't know Fuentes I think that's
significant I mean that they basically
threw Trump a life raft Trump was was
reeling from this being accused of all
these things and now yay basically came
out and confirmed he actually Trump
didn't know who he was I brought him
there oh okay I thought Milo set it up
yeah he's like no that was me and then I
got in touch with Milo and Milo brought
this guy and Trump didn't know who it
was I'm like oh okay so well okay then
all right maybe that's why they didn't
want me to do the show with them because
they were going to realize that Trump
actually wasn't at fault no well there
you go does it change your opinion of
like I know you've been following kind
of speculation about that dinner and
speculation about uh yay's campaign I
keep on calling him the wrong name does
it does this change like how you feel
about this as a potential influence on
2024
you know what man
I've heard a lot of people say that yay
could win
uh and for a lot of reasons like I
mentioned because he's a celebrity and
regular people know and like him
but not if that's
not presidential s a lot of things he's
a smart guy they say he's crazy I'm
gonna tell you we were downstairs calmly
discussing things the dude is not crazy
definitely not emotional maybe arrogant
sure a lot of high profile people are
you can accuse me of that I'm sure and
uh I think what happened now is a
display of
he doesn't need anything from me right
he doesn't and so if he doesn't get what
he wants he's done so what do you think
of the uh role of celebrities in
American politics say like obviously
we've had
um when when Trump ran for office this
is like how most Americans knew him
right he was the Celebrity Apprentice he
was a TV host like do we think there is
a market in American politics for people
who have influence but are not
necessarily trained politicians I just
want to add this comment because we were
talking about this when it was just the
the it was just me you
um yay and I think uh Cassandra and he
talked about specifically how Donald
Trump was like the Michael Jordan of
politics because he he uh he changed the
NBA and made it something totally
different and he was specifically
referring to how the political game has
been changed how it is totally different
how it's not just you know predominantly
obeying and worshiping of certain
political politician that changes his
tone when he's with a certain group so I
I think it's going to be interesting to
see how this future campaign is going to
be unfolding because right now it
doesn't look promising I don't know if
any Campaign Will unfold us yet to be
seen well that's not from you know the
information we got from I want to give a
shout out to uh Danny pauluschuck am I
pronouncing your name wrong Danny we've
had him on the show before he's he's a
good news funny he says crazy that the
one thing Kanye has been talking about
for two months somehow got brought up on
the show
I know we never could have expected it I
don't know what we were yeah we knew we
exactly was going to come up and I told
them out right I literally said to them
like if you guys want to bring that
stuff up I'm not going to sit there and
let you just say whatever you want and
they're like we know we know we know and
I was like and I and like who am I
kidding it's going to come up but we
have an opportunity to talk about the
news and they're like right right okay
like I feel like people level Levy
against you sometimes they'll call you
anti-semitic or they'll call you more
right yeah people level well they call
you negative things like how do you deal
with it if someone was in an interview
and was like there's an there's a news
outlet that tried calling me alt right
and had issue an apology no attraction
because they go after they were like Tim
Poole who was mixed race is not alt
right we apologize for the for those
statements so is that generally like if
you're in an interview and someone's
starting to kind of push back against
you like is what's your protocol like if
someone accuses me of something that
it's not true or whatever yeah or is
like you often talk about this and we
don't agree with it
okay you just let it go what am I what
what am I supposed to say like I think
it's funny uh Gizmodo reported May of I
think it was like 2018 that
conservatives were being censored on
Facebook
and so then I'm on Twitter like wow look
at this conservatives are being censored
on Facebook and they're like Tim Poole
falsely believes conservatives are being
censored on Facebook and I'm like wait
what yeah I believe what I believe I
said that the cow right now store was
one of the things that convinced me to
vote for Donald Trump because I saw how
insane things were getting and this was
so extremely dire and uh it was it was
it was a you know a lot of factors and
then I get the media reporting like
negatively that I said that I'm like I
don't care if you view it negatively I
literally said that Trump pinned the
Tweet to his page it mattered to me you
know if it matters to me I'll talk about
it yeah I think like the thing that I've
always known from being around you is
like you there's protests in China is
that is that because of China because of
this we're so influential
no sorry just like fact checking you
we're gonna put you in the view Hannah
you better stop right now I don't like
this at all uh but I mean what about you
Luke I feel like people push back on you
all the time have you ever walked out of
an interview no uh but again if you're
gonna say
some crazy stuff be prepared to back it
up
um have some facts you're gonna make
some claims back it up let's have a
debate let's have a conversation let the
best idea when that didn't happen today
and that just sucks yeah you know what
man
and he reacted as if you led the
interview like so you're anti-Semitic
I know he kind of said no he said he set
it up himself from the very beginning
he's like yeah I don't know if we should
do this I'm just gonna do this and I'm
like why are you setting this up this
way
his setup I probably should have said I
probably should have been like yay I
hear you man I respect what the story
you're getting to you want to hold off
on that for a little bit maybe we'll
talk about the news and then we can
bring the stuff up he probably would
have been like all right I feel like
there was a semantic issue here when you
use the term day and then we had
let's just keep going with the
conversation here too let's keep moving
on like because that's yeah who do I
mean by they we should have been like a
bunch of no no like as soon as he said I
shouldn't do this like yes you shouldn't
stop wait now wait we're gonna be
talking about this let's hold on hold on
does this work at this time we usually
go to Super Chat right before that I'll
give you the nod and you can go and do
whatever you need to talk about no but
then it would have happened we would
have like I would like there's things
that I need to bring up and other people
need to bring up that that's counter to
some of their ideas that need to be
talked about he didn't want to have a
conversation he thought he was going to
come in here and be able to say whatever
he wanted uninterrupted and unimpeded
and no one would question him that's
just not the real world sorry man I
think yay is a very smart guy and you
know what's sad I said too look man I
get all that stuff like the Friedman
stuff it's stupid to to keep bringing
that up I had people call me and they
were like Tim the first thing you got to
even check out the show is denounce and
I was like oh that's so dumb it's so
tired and we talked about it and they
were like you think yay is going to be
happy that you're coming out right away
and being like I denounce what you say
and I'm like everybody knows what he
said
anybody honest knows I think it's bad I
just don't agree with him on it we need
to talk about other things and United
said I want to talk about how you've
succeeded in business because we we were
talking earlier and one of the people
who work here said
yeah he's been able to go into every
industry that's rejected him and flip it
on its head and sort of take over and
I'm like I want to hear that I want to
hear how it is that he's so influential
it doesn't happen so it's like it's not
every personality who can do that look
I've I've been to antifa protests
I've I was at Occupy Wall Street Luke
was there too this is the mentality that
we have consistently argued against this
is the same and like
you know for the people who are fans of
the show how many people have stormed
off the show I'm not going to bring up
these individuals but you all know it's
not people who hold logical classical
liberal views believe in meritocracy or
who believe in having a good idea it's
people who emotionally believe a
singular group of people are the cause
of their problems they can't handle a
discussion about it when you ask someone
a question
I'll put it this way
if someone doesn't have an answer to a a
an ideology they assert they typically
Retreat to an emotional response
it's a defense mechanism I'm hurt by
this person how did they hurt you how
dare you deny my truth
a logical person says well they they
robbed my house yeah and then is there a
big difference between someone pointing
to all white males being responsible for
their problems to what other people
making those statements as well is there
a big difference I I don't think so as
well I also feel partly responsible for
this because I I told Cassandra to get
kind yay on the show I also I was
responsible for the other guests that
also there was almost a fist fight here
with uh Leonard bringing the controversy
everywhere he goes listen here you want
to be Hannah Montana
I feel responsible so I apologize it's
all my fault I don't get it I'm sorry to
the audience members for bringing
bringing them
my Twitter DMS are lighting up right now
from a bunch of high-profile people that
are commenting like they just destroyed
themselves like it doesn't look good
they they did not defend their ideas
they couldn't handle like here's the
thing I'm getting criticized because
they're like Tim why were you letting
them say those things
barely pushed back I got like 10 words
they were on for 12 minutes
um 27 27. that's a good number I like
that number honestly that's the mark
Donald Trump if you come on and can make
it to 28 you win the new record we'll
take it yeah 29 we basically let you
stay in town no but I think that's one
of like the best things that could have
happened in this scenario like if if it
was inevitable if we were doomed to have
them lock out I don't believe it was
Sage uh the best thing that you could
have offered them was a platform like
that dinner is so interesting so many
people want to know what happened and so
many wanted people want to hear from
them like this is a chance to get that
side and it was presented them like you
platformed them for them to be
themselves and the truth is they don't
like it's truly what Tim said they don't
need this platform they could have used
it to their advantage nonetheless but
they didn't need this platform he could
have gone on any any social media and
said what he needed to say about the
dinner but it's specifically the format
that it's a common conversation that
matters and yet the expectation was a
monologue well and it's the news like
that was one of the things I was really
excited about was to like have you pull
up the stories about like what's going
on with the World Cup and hearing you
know yay respond to them because again
if he is pursuing a political platform
like I uh I'm sorry to do this I don't
know a ton about his positions on things
so it really would have been interesting
to hear someone who is potentially
pursuing the office like that uh give
his perspective because I'm sure they're
interesting like
Kanye is a really interesting person
he's a really unique thinker and I think
that that is what we are all excited
about tonight like we just want to know
how like when when yay reads the news
how does he come out of the out of the
other side
I don't know I mean Leonard smirking
over here I don't know what's happening
in the chat chat room right now and
every time I read the chat I have a I
have a great time well yeah I I most of
the time I'm on the show I'm usually
snickering in the corner here playing
all the chats we don't see about Lewis
is like he has three different screens
up and you can see the chat going on one
of them I got an idea for a segment
what is it oh we're still doing news
yeah hold on this um we're still rolling
let me see if I can find this story
you're doing great buddy hold on hold on
uh give me give me a second you guys
talk about stuff while I Google I search
for something yeah Hannibal Lecter go
ahead yeah so I'm gonna sit here and
present my own thought I think we should
have another three guest show I think
that of course we should have uh Lucas
here back but then we should have Donald
Trump Elon Musk and Taylor Swift I know
that's important to all of you it's
important to me I like to have a diverse
that would be an amazing chemistry I
just really feel like we could all learn
something about the cross-section of
American culture if we brought I think
that Taylor and Elon would have some
beautiful babies do you think he'd asked
her do you think he's been like oh yeah
we got it we got a segment for first
thing tomorrow morning from
breitbart.com Kanye canceled by Kanye
walks out of Temple interview and asks
to defend ask to defend his
anti-semitism
but like here's here's the crazy thing
about it I I I was like letting him
speak about it I said okay if that's me
so some people are like Tim you know you
should you should have just let him
speak and you Tim only want to talk
about Trump because Trump's a safe
subject and he was scared about being
banned and I'm like we said okay we're
gonna talk about it right let him start
talking about it see you also were like
defend your anti-Semitism
it would have been a it would have been
a comfort it would have been a
conversation that that would have
exchanged different ideas there was
different ideas coming from different
points of view here that obviously would
have clashed the audience could have
decided which idea is better me and Tim
were sitting here with some of let's be
honest here some of the smartest most
intelligent most uh creative minds in
the entire political social industry and
we were ready to have a conversation we
were ready to challenge our beliefs
their beliefs and and and to come up
with a discourse we came here for that
conversation in the other side left and
I just feel like I don't get it though I
don't get it see that's what I think the
thing is like I think the accusation of
being anti-semitic is so radioactive
that it puts everyone involved on the
defensive both the people who want to
respond to the accusation and the people
who are levying the accusation and I can
only imagine in Connie's position that
you are in yay's position I am so sorry
yay uh that you are tense to be prepared
to respond to it because you're on the
you are on the defensive all the time oh
and I want to shout out hey Greg Greg
price you're wrong he says yay got up
and left the timcast studio less than 10
minutes into the show not true you
tweeted it at 8 25 bro the show goat
went live at 7 59. yeah it's 26 minutes
25 on the clock but uh it is what it is
I thought I thought we were going to
have that conversation and a member I
thought yeah I thought yay wanted to
actually like defend his position on it
yeah if you're gonna make some claims
back it up well and like what what would
you have liked to have heard from him
like how would you look my view on it is
so like we had Bannon on and Bannon
knows that if you question the 2020
election YouTube gives you a strike but
he also knows I don't agree with him on
it and so he like it was funny because
he like he he knows and he looks over at
Lydia and he's like I can say that can I
and then he starts you know talking
about Donald Trump and fraud and stuff
and I was like dude now you brought up
we're going to talk about it okay and
Bannon entertained the conversation of
me disagreeing with him bannon's a Savvy
smart guy
when uh we had I think the first time we
had him on and he and I argued about the
election I said Trump got anti-elected
because people assumed that Biden's
approval rating was his his uh the
enthusiasm for Biden was so low he
couldn't possibly win but somehow did
and I said but did you look at the polls
showing enthusiasm against trump it was
higher than enthusiasm for Trump
According to some pollsters and then Ben
was like yeah I like that he was
anti-elected yeah interesting that's
that's that's that's very good how often
do you have a guest on Whose views are
difficult to talk about on YouTube
because I especially with all the
vaccine stuff I feel like we've had some
where it's just it's just hard to talk
about it like I remember we had the uh
Surgeon General on from Florida but but
he said everything he was a government
official but but you know yay he had two
people in his Corner that are working
with him that are also how do I say this
uh
master debaters uh that that could talk
about these these uh subjects that have
been that have been 12 years old that
have been talking about these subjects
for years and of course are ready to
debate them so he had people in his
Corner that were here with him for him
ready to uh have his side there's three
against two when it came to this
conversation you guys had gotten like
more time to talk to Nick or any more
time to talk absolutely yeah I mean Milo
was really interesting when he was on
the show and some people have said it's
like one of the like some high profile
individuals reached out and said that
was one of the best shows I've ever seen
it's it's really interesting to hear his
thoughts someone pointed out uh Robert
Spencer and Super Chat said Milo is
purposely making yay look bad because he
really wants Trump to win do you
I thought
like with them getting Fuentes invited
to to the Trump dinner
that was like really bad for Trump right
he's getting like every Republican
coming out against him like they
seriously caused harm to Trump if Milo
wanted Revenge that was it definitely
this negated all of that yay came out
and said nope Trump didn't know who
fundus was Milo's the one who invited
him okay so Trump's in the clear now so
now I have no idea what their plan was
maybe just trolling fun notoriety
you know it might all get overshadowed
unfortunately all that information might
get overshadowed who knows do you think
could meet the fine
requirements to run for president like
right now it's a hypothetical
it's nothing in documentation right we
don't have a paper trail of an a formal
campaign I I I'm genuinely confused by
whatever it is they're trying to
accomplish to be completely honest yeah
just trolling or something so what do
you think's the best outcome from this
this this you know uh look if you're if
you're someone who disagrees with their
views I think they just
shoved their face into the mud
like I didn't yo come on
I've got people criticizing me saying I
didn't push back hard enough and I
shouldn't have let him say those things
and I'm like but then there's also the
framing that you're like the hero that
asked him to defend his anti-Semitism
yeah like choose a framing right I feel
like those things are true though we got
not even a quarter of the way through
the show right there wasn't like at
least give Tim a chance yeah let's let
some report to that love we'll have uh I
mean they tried to do just that in the
pre-show but it didn't work I'm sorry
sir we did in fact get the recorder my
my fault officially this is real life
man yeah yeah yeah I don't I don't like
people who blame their problems on
groups of people
like when Occupy Wall Street did it with
the one percent I said I mentioned this
earlier like you've got wealthy
individuals backing you uh you've got
obviously people who blame Jewish people
if you've got people who blame white
people and I'm like man stop blaming
everybody else for your problem and roll
up your sleeves and chop some Lumber
work hard I get it you know I was
mentioning this earlier I talked to it I
was talking to a woke dude years ago and
he said people don't understand what
it's like growing up being like a brown
skin like Hispanic dude in this country
where all the Billboards and everything
are white people every move you see is
white people who am I supposed to look
up to so we look up to people in other
countries we look to people who look
like us and my response was I think it's
unfortunate that you need that you see
race as a thing you need is a
requirement for what you need to look up
to but I do understand you have a family
every day you see your dad you look up
to your dad he looks like you you look
like him but then you look at what the
the country is promoting and none of
these people look anything like you so I
can I can certainly get that I I hear I
hear you but the reality is there may be
dominant groups in every country in
China it's so the white supremacy is
meaningless it's it's it's Chinese if
you're a weaker Muslim you're in serious
trouble it ain't the white people
oppressing you in the United States the
majority of the country is white and
Christian
but you can succeed and you can become a
billionaire
yay did it and then when he encounters
problems with it he decided the problem
was Jewish people I'm like I think it's
particular individuals who have it out
for you bro not not like bro the Jewish
people who work at this company have
literally nothing to do with yay's
troubles is that what he said like that
was how he ultimately viewed his
problems or yes because I I was like
what what are they they mentioned I said
what about Bezos what about you know
Shane Smith what about uh Elon and
they're like oh they all work for Jewish
people and I'm like what Bill Gates come
on man I'm sorry dude I can't buy that
advice is a great example I said this if
you really believe that I think this
might have been before the show I was
like how do you explain my show and he
said because God is on our side like
what dude like you can't say that if
someone is against me it's a specific
group of people and if we're winning
it's because God is here with us either
you as an individual regardless of race
gender orientation identity can succeed
or you think everyone is underneath the
boot of some group of people
so what role do you think I did hearing
thinking has on the American public
because I do think the points about like
we isolate uh certain racial votes we
use them as blocks to win identity
politics and identitarianism aren't
necessarily the same they overlap
identitarianism is government based on
identity so or or you know so I I should
be careful about how I say that I should
probably try to clarify better if you
think that
you are inhibited in any way or or I
should say if you believe it is
impossible because of your identity then
you are is a disservice like you are
being lied to there are uh
there are people I know from the
Philippines who may who who are
wealthier actually I think it's like
Filipino immigrants make like 90k to 120
can average in the United States it is
it is it's not the race of the
individual it is their perseverance
their willingness to work really really
hard I think the problem with
identitarianism or uh identity grievance
politics is that you start to believe
you can't succeed because of immutable
characteristics seek to blame another
group of people and then you get chaos
violence and that's what we see with you
know from occupy to the antifa to the
BLM stuff black lives matter going on
protesting calling white or calling
black people white supremacists some
like you see you see where the ideology
is bankrupt
so you get kind of someone who's Owens
who's a black woman who has conservative
opinions and they call her a white
supremacist it's like okay your
race-based politics are bankrupt that
makes no sense to me they claim that
Luke being polish is a person of color
and we joke about all the time because
Luke is a white blue blue-eyed
blonde-haired man hey my people's
struggles are real uh but but there's a
problem with generalizations there's
always exceptions to the rules and I
think when you speak in over
generalizations whether you're blaming
one particular race or all particular
white men for your problems you're just
being intellectually lazy
um I I think there there could be a real
discussion to be had on a lot of very
powerful people on a lot of very bad
people but once you just start making
lazy generalizations you do you you hurt
yourself and you hurt the major claims
that you're making because you're also
going after innocent people you're out
you're also going after people who have
nothing to do with your ills or your
problems you're going after people who
of course aren't the source of your
problems
pointing fingers and you're just hold on
and you're just pointing fingers at them
which is not fair Mary's gonna walk out
needed to occur because I don't
necessarily think that he is just making
lazy generalizations to blame a group of
people for his problems his problems are
not ordinary problems that Ordinary
People face and
to the extent that we still operate on a
meritocratic system that is how Kanye
became the success story that he is but
I think that he's trying to point out
ways that his success is now being used
against him and he feels like he's being
used as an instrument or a cog in it
much larger machine he doesn't know what
to call it maybe or uh he's not imputing
it for the right reasons but that
machine does need to be
investigated and talked about it that
didn't happen tonight and that's what's
so unfortunate about it there was just
like
there was too much miscommunication here
for that to happen he said at the
beginning of the interview it's like I'm
I'm not allowed like they can lump
together the black vote but I can't lump
together this group's Vote or what you
know something that I sent I'm
paraphrasing here and I find that
interesting I do think that we
feel I've always believed that Americans
are extremely uncomfortable talking
about race and that makes it almost
impossible to make any progress on that
front because you are so afraid of
saying the wrong thing and that's what I
think would have been maybe the best
outcome of this conversation is to get
someone else's perspective who right now
is willing to take a huge risk I
oh I know what you're saying like
definitely there are people who are
willing to blame their problems on you
know everything's out to get me this is
by you know this is the system is is
rooted for me to fail but I also think
that there are uh I think the way we
view race has creeped so much into our
government that we do have systems that
specifically are designed to lift people
up and unfortunately can make the
playing field on level and hurt some
groups of people I don't think that
we're able to fundamentally unpack how
we view race in this culture because
it's become kind of a left-wing taboo
Nick was afraid of your crystal rocks by
the way he was like please someone move
these rocks for me please before the
show when we were all talking
I would like Kanye would be in the
middle of an idea and I would be nodding
along and I would put up a few fingers
this is what I do when I signal like
I've got a thing to say like people
often say like you know Tim interrupts
all the time I do but you know it's a
show where we we do cut each other off
maybe I doodle too much look I try but I
often do I hold my hand up and like not
along like either because we got to
change the subject go on to a new
segment or go to super chats when I
would do that yay would immediately stop
and be like you want to say something
and I'd be like oh I'll keep going I was
gonna after you're finished like before
the show he was totally like I put my
hand up and he'd be like yes observation
I had reason I came up here I was
watching the show and listening and uh I
think Kanye is an empath he's uh he
works off yay thank you yay you changed
your name brother I'm struggling with
this um and he works off tone like big
time tone and in a room like this with
six people when one person asks somebody
else a question and then the third
person answers and then everyone's look
that's why he was thinking of seven
things at once at that right before he
got up and walked out
so it's just a different way to
communicate I think it I think you're
totally right in this room it's very
hard to sometimes tell like it can feel
like someone's not on your side more
than they actually are or there's more
tension maybe because people get
animated and they have to look over here
and then the screen changes like you've
been doing the show for a long time at
this point like I know you probably feel
that too when like you can't totally get
the Rhythm because at any time someone
else is going to jump in free yeah it's
like being a tornado a lot of times a
really enjoyable tornado if you're not
used to it that that's why it's
confusing to hear him compare it to the
Lex Friedman podcast because that's
one-on-one you're talking for nearly
four hours together you have complete
and utter freedom and I feel like say
whatever you want but then
this is supposed to be a conversation
that pinballs around that's nothing like
Lex Friedman right I feel like what he
was saying is he was he was expecting to
be
um I guess scripted questions or some
kind of narrative or something else that
was happening or ulterior that's what he
was referring to or just allowed to
model up right exactly which wasn't
which has never been the case for the
show it's never been like that that's
why I like it so I watched it people
wonder maybe he wasn't familiar with
like your viewpoints or how you do
things I told them before the show if
you guys expect to talk about that stuff
I'm gonna push back on them of course of
course of course
well that's why I I'm like when people
are like they staged it I'm like
okay maybe think about this
as I stated earlier if they stayed in
the show and said things that everyone
already knew they thought what's the
what's the story if they get up and
storm out the story was was put up on
the Internet within a minute of it
happening yay storms out of interview
and they never got their ideas
challenged or questioned exactly they
had two people that for for especially
for years that were specifically
debating this issue that that were
arguing this issue that that again we're
studying this issue we came to to of
course have that conversation they
didn't want to happen does walking out
just mean all publicity is good
publicity yes the moment we got into the
point of any kind of adversarial
questioning they were done and they
walked out they didn't have to have
their ideas challenged but they got the
pr I'm I feel like the human race right
now is coming together like with the
internet and we're just this weird stage
of our Evolution where we get these
really different people we're forced to
come together we have no choice if we're
going to survive and create you know
American republicanism and freedom and
stuff we have to work with people that
we do not understand or like half the
time sometimes times and it's it's just
a weird like it's like mixing oil and
water you know you see these weird
environments and things where it's too
much for somebody one day and then the
next day you're still friends you know
I digress but I I think it's to be
expected these kind of things and it's
not like a bad thing but you're also
like an empath kind of yeah I don't know
yeah yeah maybe it would have gone
differently and better if you had been
in the room actually I think there's
always more you know it's worth seeing
in all perspectives there's someone who
like when I talk to you I feel like you
are one thousand percent attentive to
what I'm saying and maybe the format
that Kanye was in sorry yay was in here
uh without you involved in the
conversation just didn't feel that way
like he didn't feel heard we did have a
good conversation for a show about
parlor and I'm like I want it what do
you think about parlor well I want to
Federate it with mines uh Rumble and
Twitter so that they can all
interoperate he was like what's that
exactly and we talked about that he was
super down with that we didn't get to
talk about graphene yet but we will we
will you have plans you're gonna call
them later I mean I think one of the
things mile has been on the show before
so hopefully he would have familiar
familiarized Kanye with like the format
and maybe that was just not like Lost in
Translation would you have Nick back on
his own Ian handled for five minutes you
got a brother okay would you have Nick
back on his own like can we have these
guests separately or was the power of
the interview that all three were here
at this point every day every way I'd
have all three of those guys back on
their own they each deserve to speak um
and hopefully they'll get a chance to uh
I I personally would have I'm a very
open-minded
um sometimes maybe a little too radical
a little too eccentric I'll have people
on that like why are you interviewing
the devil Ian well I mean let's find out
why people think he's so evil let's get
down to it yeah did it take you a while
to adjust to this format because it is
like with looking at the news and
responding to it like you're not
necessarily here to discuss your
expertise did that take you a minute to
fall into line with yeah first it felt
like a jam session I was treating like a
jam session your team will come in I'd
make as much noise as he was we were
just splattering and he would get
frustrated and kept getting and was like
this is it at one point he kind of said
listen I'm the orchestra like I'm the
the what do they call it the guy that's
leading the Orchestra conductor Tim's
like I'm the conductor I'm like that's
right I'm first trumpet it's not a jam
session we're not equals here Tim is is
conducting this environment at least
that's how I treat the yeah it's called
Tim cast you know it's not called All of
Us cast not communist cast if you're not
having your ideas challenged what are
you doing I mean I mean come on and we
talk over each other me and Tim disagree
we argue we debate all the time we had a
big debate about Bill Gates and we saw
things differently we had a whole debate
about you know the the Jabs we had a
whole debate about so many different
issues and it's fine you know it's okay
and I think you know more and more
you're you're seeing a lot of parallels
from from the left on the right so you
know a lot of the wokeness a lot of the
blaming everything on generalizations a
lot of the kind of more emotional based
aspects a lot of the
the the the the kind of ways that people
handle themselves asking for more
government intervention I I think it's
almost directly the same in a lot of
instances and I think that's a fair
critique that needs to be criticized
especially with people calling for more
government especially people for uh who
are trying to blame everything on one
particular group I I I think more than
ever we need conversation we need debate
we need paradigms shattered we need them
broken we need to get rid of this
thinking that that some man or some
government is going to come in and fix
everything for you because they're not
no one's coming to save you you can only
save yourself personal responsibility
decentralization localized Community
efforts are the way that this is going
to be solved
you women go start your own view show
stop being rude and interesting
thank you very much I'm talking about a
very specific issue that I think is
worth mentioning now because again there
are a lot of parallels between the left
and the right they're essentially
calling for the same thing acting the
same way and and representing them the
same way now you women go squawk at each
other
is there a specific story you would have
liked to discuss with Connie tonight I
mean that was the thing that I really
with I am so sorry I'm not doing this on
purpose you know that we already we went
over this we already talked we already
talked about this like it's like I said
yes like Hannah we already talked about
we I said hey we I wish we would have
talked about this this and this I no but
I'm just curious can you remind me what
you said
um hardly Pastor Nick the Canadian
psychological operations uh Dave
Chappelle essentially warning uh on
Oprah what what he went through seems
like exactly what kind he went through
and this is what yay went through and
this is why I specifically brought up
um him being institutionalized because I
think there's a bigger conversation to
be had with this Canadian military guy
who worked in psychological operations
that is one of the bigger players in
Hollywood I think there's a bigger I
think there's a bigger conversation to
have about that there's a bigger
conversation to have about Balenciaga
and all the occult secret stuff that
they've been kind of showing to the
point where they have now deleted their
Instagram and their Twitter I think
there's a bigger conversation to have
about you know JP Morgan and Chase and
and Jeffrey Epstein so these were the
issues that I really wanted to get into
because I thought they were extremely
important to to highlight the the larger
parallels of what he's warning about to
how other people have been affected by
it and when I brought up the meds before
specifically I think it's worth talking
about because when you look at the text
message that he released between himself
and Harley Pastor Nick who essentially
looks like he was the one that
institutionalized him because he he was
at his home he's the one that that was
threatening to to drug him and to put
him in Zombieland forever to the point
where playing with his children wasn't
going to be the same ever again that
that was a huge threat made against yay
right this is this is why I think it's
important to talk about ssri's uh
psychotropics uh all the drugs
especially with the way that they have
affected individuals like Jordan
Peterson uh to think that these drugs
that that big Pharma gives out like
they're just candy doesn't have any
long-term Mental effects I think is is a
conversation that that should be had it
shouldn't be a controversial one but
it's clearly there's there's a link
there why do you think people are afraid
to talk about you might have views on
this too like why do you think ssris or
you know they call them mood stabilizing
drugs or whatever like why do you think
people are so afraid to discuss that but
there's a big industry there's a huge
big Pharma industry that that has their
money in their hands and everywhere that
I think is worth criticizing that I
think is worth talking about and this is
why I I wanted to bring up do you feel
the same way about like lithium or
antipsychotic drugs as you do about
ssris I I think there's a far bigger
portion of the population taking ssris
than
exactly I think I think the a lot of a
lot of the the studies a lot of the the
findings haven't really been officially
kind of delved out I think each person
is unique each person is individual just
like their brain chemistry and once you
start tinkering and messing around with
people's brain chemistry when they're
all different I think this leaves for a
recipe uh for a disaster so as far as
those two particular uh different kind
of substances I'm not an expert I'm not
a scientist I'm not here trying to give
you guys any kind of medical advice
that's the last thing I would want to do
I know you would but what kind of doctor
would you be did you ever want to go to
medical school I I have a lot of jokes
that I can make here right now but I
won't um no but I'm being serious like
did you you've always been interested in
Wellness ever since I've known you like
Have You Ever Wanted
study medicine in any serious capacity
well yeah I don't think you need
licenses or permission to study anything
I've been looking into a lot of the the
scientific studies when Dr Drew was was
on we talked about uh paxilvid I thought
that was a very interesting important
conversation to have and I think I've
held my weight when it came to debating
a lot of those uh very important
controversial ideas but um again
everyone has their own decision then
this is what uh me and you were talking
about when we first saw each other he
picked up a bar I'm like you know what
that that's poison here let me get you
some good stuff and we got him some
stuff without any seed oils without any
high fructose corn syrup and I'm like
you don't want to touch this you don't
want to touch this you want to be
careful of this and he was and this is
why he when he left as he was leaving he
was like am I detained I'm like you're
not detained he's like I want to work
with you on food I'm like okay it's like
you don't you don't owe us anything it's
fine exchange numbers no do you feel
like the American public is generally
empowered to like be a like do they know
enough about nutrition or absolutely
medical industry like what would be the
best way to change that in your
perspective because you are you are sort
of self-educated in this in this sphere
yeah absolutely I mean each person the
best health advice I could give to an
individual is to do what is right for
you as an individual nothing is at all
cure answer to everything everything is
based on an individual you got anything
to report because I'm back I'm about to
piggyback of what you're saying Luke
about Kanye maybe having stress or yay
sorry buddy I don't know if it's fair to
kind of speculate but I think it's fair
to have that discussion right based off
what happened to them those text
messages and how the industry tries to
control people with these psychotropic
drugs and has tried to do it with the
Dave Chappelle who on record came out
and said there was people running around
me saying that I was crazy trying to get
me to take these big Pharma drugs he
escaped to Africa and literally ran away
from 50 million dollars in a contract
because he felt like he was going to be
forcefully drugged by people in the
industry that are trying to control him
and trying to feminize him and dress him
up as a little girl there's a big
difference between taking drug and being
drugged I have a very close friend that
was drugged it he still has
post-traumatic stress from the
experience it's not just the memory of
the of the woe the walls are moving
around it's like who did this to me am I
even safe is life even real yeah and
that follows you for or can follow
someone for years so I think there's uh
that conversation could be had I'd like
to talk to Kanye about I mean if we were
like going deep one night and about our
past and stuff and you're like do you
have post-traumatic stress all right
let's go to Super Chat sorry
yeah yeah yeah uh I didn't mean to cut
you off it's just
my phone's getting slammed I got a bunch
of people messaging me uh it's funny a
lot of the people who are like don't do
this Tim are now going you did a good
thing tonight too oh my God
what do we do we do nothing they're
gonna reframe it to the point where they
said Tim Poole kicks Kanye out of the
studio put a bat right now on like which
way this gets spun like banishes yay or
out of his studio for anti-Semitism
terrible people I wanna I wanna announce
um you know we're gonna have a members
only show which I guess we don't have
but
we do still have a members only segment
with them so we had a crew go out and
film them on their Journey here and then
I guess what they were doing before they
got here
I'm assuming they filmed them on the way
out so we'll we'll have at least that up
I suppose but um let's read some of
these super chats
and I'll try and read as many people as
who who like and don't like people are
saying we should have talked about fish
sticks people have pointed it out all
right Beau Rye says sorry yay is a
freaking baby Tim put up hardly any
resistance and just simply asked what he
means how can you be present if you
can't even explain yourself he has to
talk to Media politicians if he's
president yeah I mean I gotta say dude
if he was going to be running for
president it would have been just
someone yelling at him the whole time
you know what I mean imagine imagine yay
sitting down with Xi Jinping
and then him being like hey man you know
you're building these military bases and
South China Sea and then yay and then
she just just tells him he's a weak
pathetic man and that he has no strength
and he has nothing he can do to stop him
as he ain't gonna just like walk away
yeah I don't know and then what I don't
think that there was ever going to be a
real campaign but like I'm on camera
saying that that's my prediction and if
I'm wrong then clip me go ahead but I
don't think that there's going to be a
real we talk to them privately and it
looks like they're taking it yeah you
can learn magic you gotta teach yay
magic dude you think the words instead
of say them when you look at someone in
the eyes and your body language does the
speaking for you even if they don't
understand your Lang your English or
whatever if they're Chinese it still is
the form of really legit communication
the rebellious grizzly bear says hey Tim
cast crew crew people who only want to
have a one-sided conversation don't
belong in politics how can things really
change without having a back and forth
this is a major problem in politics
today I agree and I gotta feel like I
was I was I I didn't I watched The Lex
fredman thing I don't I don't watch like
the whole thing I don't watch a whole
lot of other shows but I watched I
watched it on while I was doing other
things I guess that's what people do
with podcasts yeah and particularly I
watched the anti-semitic stuff the stuff
that yay was saying and I felt that Lex
was talking in circles like I just I was
not interested in it and that's exactly
what I told them before I was like guys
I get it I know what you think can we
talk about what's going on with you guys
in the news so we can elaborate on on
this and they didn't want to do it it is
what it is
all right
what do we got here
none says yay's view is notwithstanding
the show's format is flawed no room for
guests to speak when Tim's ego takes up
the whole room Adam Crigler was right
hey I said I'd read ones that were not
fond of me either it's funny because
people are like Tim wants to be the
smartest guy in the room and he's got a
big ego but I'll literally read you
insulting me and I'll have on a whole
bunch of other people who are either in
in different areas more knowledgeable
than I am and I'll give a special shout
out to Sheamus Coughlin who I argued
with adamant that I was correct about
what abortion was specifically on the
legal side and Sheamus told me I was
wrong turned out to be right and then I
had to apologize to him later saying I
was completely wrong about that you were
right I had the legal definition totally
incorrect so that's the reason why you
have other people on we we bullied him
off air don't worry we keep oh they're
throwing pies at me
Hannah's evil I'm really mean I don't
know it's totally she gives him swirling
I swear I got no hair Jacqueline stoico
says Tim cast need a behind the scenes
cameraman to follow them downstairs like
Jerry Springer would have been useful a
couple times already I think we have
three cameras on or something I wonder
if Wesley got it well the thing is like
we were all watching it and like we see
his coat go behind you and I was like
who was that and then we get enough
people sprinting to be like we've got to
intercept like what's going on we should
have a Jerry Springer camera guy outside
the door ready to go
that'll be good but who's the father
ghost Crusader says you should have
pre-recorded the interview tin you did
nothing wrong but I think Milo showed
him the episode with you and Milo and
yay thought it was going to be like that
where he can just keep talking that's a
good observation I agree with that I do
I do well you know but even with Milo we
were like wait wait hold on I want to
say this and then right we interrupted
we interrupted Milo a couple times did
you push back on things Milo's saying I
don't think Milo was saying like I did
yeah specifically he's worshiping the
altar of Donald Trump and I was like
wait are you really going to be
worshiping Donald Trump like are you
going to be you know worshiping you know
you're bringing up like foreign policy
stuff exactly but look look
I explained this to them before the show
when Milo came on he had not spoken
publicly in in almost five years yeah
and so when he started talking and just
was was going off I was like this is a
stream of Consciousness that he's been
holding it holding on to and to hear his
thoughts is is really interesting
considering Trump's going to be
announcing or whatever
when they came here I said we know what
you guys have said that's been the news
we can talk about it who am I kidding
it'll come up but let's talk about new
issues right like that was my point okay
then you want to bring and I said if you
guys want to bring that up I will be
pushing back don't expect me to just sit
back and Milo's like yes yes of course
of course all I wanted for you him was
to look at yay and be like so would you
build the border wall like I just needed
to know some platforms here or Julian
Assange what's his position on Julian
Assange I think he also talked about a
Ubi Universal basic income that he wants
to I've only ever heard him refer to
like the Utopia he wants to build but I
don't know what that means I'm gonna
walk out I'm out of here
I remember you're all welcome finally
Leonard is leaving when we had Milo on a
couple weeks ago for the first 15
minutes I kept seeing Tim like put his
hand up like that gesturing like he's
gonna respond and it it was impossible
and like Milo kept going like a
steamroller oh hey Luke and uh and then
at 15 minutes
just he just was like what this I gave
up he just went along for the ride after
that and we just let Milo take it yay
was wearing a very large puffer jacket
that probably well that's because it's
like 64 degrees
his coat's so big it's freezing he's a
secret yes he wasn't wrong about that he
was right it is cold like are you guys
do you have a window open it's always
amazing yeah someone had the AC on oh
the window was open that's what I was
called but I won another room and and it
was on it was on cooling who's well I
mean I guess it's better this room is
cold than not hot no one in the Super
Chat cares about this conversation so uh
I will also mention people like there
are things happen I'm like my phone's
blowing up you know what I mean like
I've got it there's a lot more to
booking people than just uh like calling
them and saying come hang out so I'll
just leave it at that and so uh one
example is security and how we handle
that and uh other things so you know
I'll just say that all right let's let's
see what we got here
Gabriel Lopez says Tim you are defending
the people destroying his life he
realizes a waste of time and cut his
losses I wasn't defending the people
destroying his life I was asking him who
was doing it in fact I wanted him to
name those people which is why we
brought up was a guy Pasternak yeah
Harley pasternack right and so what I
wanted to do was name the individuals
but he was adamant that it was just
Jewish people and I'm like okay dude
there's miscommunication yeah maybe but
like I wasn't trying to insult him I'm
like can you explain who this is who are
these people and when I said face like
what do you mean by they like oh come on
dude have you guys ever had that
phenomenon where it's you and two other
people and then like the two other
people start talking at you and they're
both kind of giving you like their have
you ever had that happen and it it's
like immediate defensive mode for me
when I have that and there's three of us
and I'm like whoa hold on yeah there's I
bet essence of that creeps into people
around here because it's a big show with
and then the energy moves so quick
around here that's why I wish that the
the subject matter could have been
something like lighter at some points
like I would have loved to hear Kanye's
sorry yay's thoughts about I'm
contagious about fashion or about
entertainment or about religion any
number of things without derailing
instantly to yeah it's like let's get
the car out of the mud before we start
the car wasn't actually in the mug we
didn't have to do that well he brought
it up we yeah we brought it up I've
recorded that pre-show but if we should
have we should have recorded the
previous conversation I know it was it
was actually a really interesting normal
conversation it happens all the time in
the pre-show yeah but and he's a
beautiful dude Kanye a human like when
you make I make architect with him and
see they were so like he's a normal like
a really good guy they were talking
about are some sins more sinful than
others and then yay asked Milo about
like a specific Saint or like some
certain passages and I'm like but we
were like we like get up we're grabbing
water and like we're changing the lights
and we're doing the cameras so we do
really just don't record it do you think
like I mean he's done other Round Table
type interviews like is there anything
else about this situation that you think
like you were saying before like it
feels more tense than maybe it is you
don't have someone who's maybe it was
really cold in here that might have
something to do with it but you have a
jacket on where he keeps it he had one
on he had a big puffy jacket on that
might have something to do he hasn't
done media appearances with both Milo
and Nick presents that was the first
time that that happened yeah I know
you're because you're like a Nick fan
yeah sure this is like a pass uh I well
he was supposed to go on pop culture
crisis with you guys afterwards yeah
that was the plan and I had a lot of
questions that I was wanting to ask yay
um but unfortunately that's not gonna
happen well it could happen I mean this
is just like it's an example of what has
to happen for us to have this
conversation in public right because
we're gonna need to bring people in that
we don't necessarily think we agree with
Cloud Schwab could be in here next week
like we and that would be a good thing
yeah hell yeah I would love to talk to
the client I would love to talk to the
bug man I'd love to talk to Bill Gates I
would love to talk to all these people
yeah
um and have those hard conversations and
have those difficult conversations do
you think you know what's best for
everyone else let's actually let's
actually debate it let's actually have
that conversation
what were you guys talking about when I
was outside medical psychosis and if you
need to go to medical school to become a
doctor
um I would pose that maybe comes come
and times Luke is our new city Doctor
Luke had pointed out how con or yay may
have been stressed since uh they had
basically drugged him when they take him
to the hospital and I thought there's
also like a level of post-traumatic
stress if you've been drugged it's
different than taking a drug willingly
Armani says Tim says we have to treat
people like individuals when yay refer
to certain people yet Tim never stepped
in when Sheamus or anyone else has gone
on a homophobic tirade calling us
degenerates and that is 100 not true in
fact I argue a lot about it to the point
where some people yell at me like when
we were talking about trans people and
Dylan Mulvaney and then I was saying
like these weird trolls do not represent
trans people and like yeah I'm I'm like
left lib but probably like Center left
so
Free Speech Liberty you know we all have
our issue we all have our issues that we
love to talk about when someone believes
that a government is the solution to any
problem it just it just straight
straight up like gets me activated I
gotta get going I gotta be like hey no
like that's because that's my own
personal beliefs that's my bigger truths
that I'm willing to stand on and debate
and have a conversation on
yeah and uh uh you know let's just read
some more
all right Mission says Tim can we just
Chuck it up that this was an unfortunate
situation not a setup not your bad on
questions just an unfortunate set of
circumstances it's just disappointing
that yay responded that way I think
that's fair to say yeah
um
like I was saying before like I don't
know what they got out of this like
maybe that just shows that nobody
planned for any of this to happen I
don't think yeah yeah is just uh
look man he's volatile well no I'm just
being like if if he doesn't need this
why is he here if he's not getting what
he wants he's gone right
I remember when I worked for vice
everyone at the office's attitude was
that they were lucky to be there and
when I left they were like oh you're
leaving and I was like yeah and they're
like why would you leave I'm like what
do you mean they're holding me back
they're not getting me what I need I
don't need I don't want to be here like
I have I have something I need and
someone else is offering me it like yeah
and his his attitude is probably like
what am I doing here with this guy I
don't need him yeah he's right yeah he
owes me nothing but none of them do I'm
not even I'm like look I'm disappointed
the show didn't work out we had a lot of
we had plans for the after show and
stuff like that but I'm I'm not mad I
mean it's like a crazy exciting night it
is what it is
you know yeah same reason I didn't go to
the Halloween party I didn't show up
because I'm I get freaked out and lar
with lots of emotions it's just this
empathic thing I like that's why I'm in
my room 98 of the time go exercise bro
yeah we got to do that kickboxing class
yeah you're right because that'll help
the emo and probably yay could stand to
do a little exercise too to to help
control in this hot moment that we're
going through as Humanity uh there yeah
I understand why why someone might want
to distance themselves from high energy
expense Spence says wait Trump gets
criticized but you purposefully invited
all three uh-huh I'm not running for
president and Trump gets criticized
because it's politics and I'll get
criticized all the same and like I
mentioned there were people saying Tim
don't host those people how dare you now
they're going you did a really great job
yeah yeah when this is my issue with
like the woke grievance politics
if you say like I'm gonna go talk to
this person they'll be like don't do it
don't do it look at um when Vice covered
Charlottesville and then all the leftist
journalists are giving them Awards oh
okay when Vice goes and interviews white
nationalists they win an award for it
because they they because it turns out
in the end they made them look bad but
if any other journalist says I'm gonna
go interview like no no don't do it
don't do it it's wrong when I said I was
going to go to Sweden I advise people
telling me don't go you'll help Trump
I'm like what do you mean I'll help
Trump if Trump is wrong I'll prove them
wrong no no don't do it then when Vice
themselves go to Charlottesville with a
white nationalist they get an award
these people are total Hypocrites man
and many times they don't even push back
or debate these ideas they just kind of
present them as is so that's another you
know topic for discussion peas and
butter says they needed timcast platform
they would not be here if they did not
need you
I just I I man
people who live in the grievance World
get angry and don't want to hear it they
don't want to be on camera they don't be
interviewed they want to be able to say
whatever they want because they know
they're right but they can't stand up to
scrutiny so if you've got an idea
and you can't handle someone saying
something like what do you mean by that
and then you just storm out I don't
think you mean anything I think you
don't know what you're talking about
that's it
I think what happened here's what I
think I think yay's life is being
destroyed by a handful of powerful
individuals many of them happen to be
Jewish I think he immediately sees that
and says this must be it he makes a
tweet about it and I think didn't he
clarify he met specific people yes he
did and then he gets in touch with
certain others who are like no no you
were right the first time and then start
agreeing with him and and you know
telling them yes and then he says okay
but then he can't actually back those
ideas up because there's nothing behind
them right
yeah there's women don't don't conflate
Rothschild's banking Empire with Judaism
that's for sure yeah
okay and shell Roth's child I like the
way you say that like your personal
slogan I'm always telling people put it
on the wall that's for sure it's like an
embroidered fellow in your room
I just got silk pillowcases someone
please embroider that pillow and send it
as a fan mail yeah that'd be great put
on the wall behind us I mean I've said
it a hundred times tonight but I am just
sad that we didn't get the opportunity
to have yay explain both his views on
this this issue but also what I really
want to know is what are your platforms
if you're seeking political office I
want to know what your stance is look at
look at what Milo said when yay brought
up the you know who who he has an issue
with like
when he brought up this this grievance
political position Milo said it's the
hypocrisy that people are tired of why
are they allowed to say one group of
people but not another group of people
if that's his position for yay 24
Trump's got nothing to worry about yeah
if yay came on this platform and said
Trump knew who Fuentes was Trump was all
about it Trump believes in it and then
said and we're gonna we're gonna work on
fixing the borders and like that would
have actually hurt Trump I think what
happened tonight was the best thing that
could have happened to Trump it's kind
of weird like if this was Milo's Revenge
he didn't get it right he just saved
Trump
whatever I don't know I don't know what
his plan was people were like I gotta
message people are like hey they're
using you Tim they're trying to use you
and I'm like what do you think it is
when someone goes on my show do you
think like anyone who comes on the show
ever is just like I'm doing this for
Tim's benefit
yeah they're like I want to go on the
show to get more followers give you
promote my book from my movie come on
man come on man no we just do it to be
nice to you we don't want you to be
sitting here alone talking to yourself
yeah uh AC your says yay opened with I'm
going to walk if you do not 100 agree
with me you just say that weird yeah not
the 100 agree with me part but he did
say I'm not gonna I'm not gonna have a
conversation like this I'm not gonna
djz says applauded by the media clear
sign you were wrong I don't know the
immedi the media's plus Breitbart that
wrote that but I'm getting uh uh
commentators like just political pundits
yeah also like wrong about what like I
think you were right to have them on
like it would have been a really
interesting conversation it's their
decision how they conduct themselves in
the room and if they want to stay in the
room that's not up to you I'll be honest
it really was a good conversation
regardless that he left or that they
left 30 minutes of Awesomeness and then
about 35 minutes of Awesomeness listen
to you guys talk about it afterwards and
then you guys came in and it was still
good now it's even better because I'm
here yeah Ian came in saved it I was
looking for you I was like where were
you I was like I couldn't find you I
went downstairs oh you did I talked to
them I tried to get them back I almost
went out there to see him before they
left but I thought you don't want to
mess with it the energy I just want to
kind of let it flow and like you're
saying an empath like do you want 100
people just like dogs where are you
going when you want to be alone you want
to be alone yeah that's what I so
there's a few things we're going to ask
like Milo in the Pastor said he's Jewish
now he says he's not uh Milo called
Kanye called yay sorry gay before at
least it's been reported I've not
exposed lacing the sweets one thing that
we did get I did ask him about like as
we're getting ready for the show there's
a post going around that's apparent
purportedly For Milo talking about how
the United States need to needs to put
Christian interests above Jewish
interests and Milo he didn't get a
chance to talk about like this is what I
wanted to talk about like hey wait
there's news Milo said he didn't say
that he reposted that he was sharing
what someone else had said and it's like
the full context isn't even there he
said he he uh wouldn't have phrased it
that way but some of the points were
correct would have been great if he was
here to ask those mention those
questions then there was also the claims
that Juan does as disparaged black
people but was here working with with
and for yay yeah we didn't get a chance
to get any of that stuff so it's almost
like they couldn't well I I can't you
know here's what's sad
Milo and Nick getting up and walking out
because yay did come on guys yeah
seriously bro you're like both of you
are high profile personalities I'll tell
you before before the show
yay said you know I've raised the
profile of these guys I said uh you know
and I was mentioning doing these shows I
said uh yay's profile could not be any
higher I mean before or after this it's
like it's crazy everybody wants to know
what he's doing and uh that was kind of
a joke uh I suppose it was being silly
like you know everybody everybody in
this room has got some kind of career
but why would you just walk out because
yay did
right I mean I think they think of
themselves as a trio they're all part of
his campaign and he's sort of shredding
them would you have Nick back would you
have I know we had Milo before would you
have them back I think we should
potentially have them both back but like
the issue is if they're gonna walk out
because yay did it's like are they
leading this conversation or are they
just here for the ride yeah cause if I
if me and you went on a show and you got
pissed off at the host and walked out
I'd probably stay
I think that'd be the right move
yeah like what are you supposed to do
because if you work for if he's I don't
think I would ever do that though right
yeah right yeah that's the first thing
okay somebody clipped that if Tim ever
walks out of an interview I may maybe I
don't I don't want to say that because
I'm like I don't know man everybody's
human I mean I've probably walked out of
some something before I don't know if an
interviewer is intellectually dishonest
and not willing to engage in a real
conversation I think that you're
understandably going to disengage right
I I yeah I mean I I think yeah just
didn't I mean I don't think that that
was the case with you you're not even an
interviewer you're just having a
discussion I like that he compared me to
Lex Friedman yeah oh yeah
can I get the uh brownie points from the
YouTube algorithm the same like
biology or the the connection is that
you and Lex are like logicians you guys
are both into logic very very strong
logic and Kanye is more emotional yeah
and that so we sensed the the logic in
the in the room
Sean Alexander says you can praise Jews
as a group but you can't criticize them
as one group interests exists let me let
me point something out when Yae was
talking about how you can say the black
vote but you can't say Jewish people are
are doing this thing it's like well hold
on there a minute Jewish people also in
like in New York City for instance
uh well actually I shouldn't say New
York City because the wave of crime has
changed things but they they do create
demographics based on on Jewish people
like they do have a Jewish demographic
based on voting and voting preferences I
lived in uh um bed style and it was a
very very strong deep Hasidic community
and their politics were were very
I I don't know what the right word is
but like unique to that area is the
right way to say I suppose when there
were protests over certain issues it was
this one like coveted lockdown they were
protesting specifically them you could
point out Jewish people in New York are
protesting nobody got mad about that
they get mad that like a handful of rich
people are hurting you so you blame
those guys you know the the the the
people in New York City the Hasidic Jews
were being chased and beaten in the
street like that's bad that shouldn't
happen because just because they're
Jewish those people and with with those
clothes are not doing anything to
anybody they're minding their own
business they're having families they're
going to synagogue they're good people
and evil greedy corporate people that
people that are using corporations to
control the world should not hide behind
the veil of a religion if you're gonna
call yourself Jewish and you're not
living by the tenets of the faith then
you're a demon if you're doing that with
Christianity then you're abusing reality
and you're not
you're good
I feel like we're about to go into a
sermon Julie bear says I picked a good
night to be a first time listener I mean
maybe not
I didn't get to listen then yeah also
like this is not normally the structure
of the show we don't normally just play
musical chairs can we turn into a drama
show we are the soap opera mcchilla says
Milo knew exactly how it would look to
connect Nick and Kanye to Trump it's
already kick-started the racial argument
against his campaign convenient Milo has
been allowed to surface recently and now
this uh I think elon's gonna reinstate
Milo like
soon at Nero and potentially Nick too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and he should
Nero is an interesting username for uh
that's a professor it's funny you could
tell he was going yeah that's true
maybe he'll change it like a nihilistic
period why couldn't we talk about that
yeah I mean the the it's unfortunate
that let off with a Twitter I should
have just pressed record the moment they
sat down right yeah I mean literally
should have yeah I mean that's a big
mistake on my part hindsight but let him
know beforehand of course well if you
would let them know then it would have
changed the whole vibe so but that it's
so weird that when the cameras were not
rolling the conversation was calm and
about faith philosophy and when when we
got to the stuff about you know like
when I said I know it's going to come up
I'm push back they said we want to talk
about the Christian values that need to
be restored in this country and I was
like well that's interesting but then
instantly it devolves into I am going to
make these assertions and and demand
that no one actually actually ask any
questions I gotta ask yay this question
but I wonder if there's a difference
between doing a show pre-recorded where
there's six of us listening to it or
doing one live where there's 50 000
people 100 000 people also if that
energy of those hundred thousand people
was heightening the situation because at
one point I looked down at my keyboard
and kind of lost track and that was when
Kanye was like it was that exact moment
that Kanye was like I I don't remember
why I brought up kids I was thinking
about seven things I was like God I just
lost track of it and then so did he
what's
that was my one of my favorite moments
when he's like yeah sometimes I'm just
thinking about seven things I was like I
100 relate to you right now it can be
did she have a screen in front of him or
was he just no okay djz says Lex also
tried to be the one to correct yay's
wrong think that's why he says it's the
same save adversal questions for the two
debaters
or do you mean same ever so
um
you know I literally wanted to be like
yeah you're allowed to think what you
want to think I'm not I I I I I I don't
think I'm gonna change his mind that's
why I told him before the show like
people know you're saying these things
obviously people disagree with what
you're saying obviously you found people
who agree with you tell me about what
you're doing in politics and what
happened with Trump explain now that
you're in these prominent positions now
you're in the news you're having an
impact tell the people why well you know
he did he did when I said why politics
why Trump he said Jewish people well
okay the people heard it loud and clear
that's exactly what your campaign and
platform is and now they know and this
is why I believe in free speech because
I genuinely thought they were going to
try to have something to talk about and
if the only thing they can talk about is
that they hate a group of people or
they're concerned I shouldn't say like
that they're concerned a group of people
have it out for them
no one's going to vote for you and you
will not amass any political power and
it turns out sunlight might actually be
the best disinfectant yeah
I I want to say this I'm not mad at him
um I don't know exactly what happened
I'm trying to text them and say like
what's going on I'm not gonna cry about
it
you know what I mean these things happen
and I'll say it again yeah you owes me
nothing literally nothing he he's his
own guy uh I I hope I hope he finds his
path man I hope he finds his path
all right let's just try and grab a
couple more here some of the my later
ones
all right
Brian says yay's point about the black
vote versus the Jews and identitarianism
was spot on how do you reconcile that I
did and I'll reconcile it again the
black vote is a handful of working class
poor wealthy basically every single
individual and the Tendencies they have
towards voting when Kanye is talking
about Jewish people he's not talking
about cultural identity politics
conservatism Tendencies to vote liberal
otherwise he's saying because there's a
handful of powerful wealthy people who
happen to be Jewish it is Jewish people
who have it out for me and I'm like
yo like my my guy and my employee who
are downstairs and are very Jewish they
actually like your music they're fans
they just don't like what you're saying
about them they don't have it out for
you at all that's that's the distinction
why why insult people who actually like
you why make them your enemies because
you've chosen to attack their identity
instead of the argument yeah
that that's very different if you want
to come out and say Jewish people in New
York vote this way nobody's going to get
mad at you they're going to be like
that's true they are very religious
they're conservative they tend to vote
these certain ways if you're going to
say that there are a lot of liberal
Jewish people in New York that tend to
vote this way yeah that's to call the
demographic we do that all the time if
you're going to come out and say that
BLM is all black people and they're the
ones causing the rights you're wrong
because black lives matter is actually a
bunch of white people like I I hate that
people are uh you like I just put that
look man I'm in Portland and I'm
watching The Proud boys March and I'm
looking at antifa antifa is a bunch of
white people screaming racial slurs and
a black proud boy and I'm like these you
see man and they call the proud boys
white supremacists and I've told the
story before the black proud boy got
angry and he took it personally and he
went across the street crossed the line
between the cops and a white white proud
boy stopped him and said stop don't let
him get to you man they're trying to get
to you and he grabbed his hand and said
you're my brother we're brothers don't
take the bait something like that and I
was like that's so crazy when it when it
was anti-fun in front of a ice Detention
Center screaming racial slurs at a black
ice agent I'm like dude
these are the people that I have a
problem with the racists the
anti-semites the people who think that
your worth is based on what you look
like or how you or your your religion
identity no obviously religion plays a
bigger role than your race certain
religions are very very you know like
extreme I get it but I'm gonna talk to
someone about their ideas and have an
argument as an individual and not blame
an entire group of people
I get it man and I'll say this too
obviously demographics have beliefs and
directions but Kanye wasn't talking
about that he was saying they referring
to Jewish people are trying to take his
money and put him in jail and I'm like
dude
they are not some people are
the overwhelming majority 99.99999 don't
in fact I bet a whole bunch of them
actually our fans until you started
saying this stuff they was actually that
was the vague moment that everything got
heightened and then he left was because
I was talking about establishment Powers
Elites corporate press the people who
want Power the woke this is the thing
when we say woke they think Jewish
people
interesting yeah because who's they I
think I know who when when yay and and
them like before the show when I
mentioned something about cancel culture
he said he he didn't say woke sjw he
said Jewish people I see and I was like
you don't seriously people are kind of
creating a demon creature like the woke
mob like we've kind of created that or
at least I feel like I have
inadvertently uh that I've created like
a demon because who is it I don't know
until I see their eyes
it's a it's a it's a it's a reference to
occult ideology yeah it's a reference to
uh an idea and I'll even say this
I I say it all the time like I have
friends who are leftists and people are
like Tim's lying it's not true I'm like
no dude it's literally true they when
that tweet went viral where I said that
there was a grooming thing at Club Q and
that we need to prevent the violence but
also stop grooming they tried claiming
that I was promoting like is it a funny
thing they're like spamming my Wikipedia
trying to claim my endorse to this or
condone it I'm like yo my tweet thread
was literally like stop advocating for
violence against people even the people
you hate the most we need law
enforcement to handle these things
they take it completely out of context
when I said that I have left his friends
who are like bro how could you tweet
that and I had to talk to him and argue
with him and be like guys that you know
that's not what I'm saying and they're
like yeah but the way it came off and
I'm like well so be it dude like I
literally said stop calling for violence
I'm advocating or violence if you think
it's the other way around then that's
you not me
anyway
you guys want to get any final thoughts
before I guess we wrap up
uh you go first
it already uh went around in circles a
couple times yeah I feel like all I have
to say is what I've said at least 57
times which is like R.I.P this really
interesting conversation that could have
been is this our outro I knew you I
think this is the outro yeah I'll say
Kanye come back yeah man come back to
pop culture no just on my show please
his name is yes I mean that's the that's
the song for yes yeah yeah could you
imagine yes look we wanted a RNA yay was
gonna go on pop culture crisis too uh
with Milo but could you imagine
know like there's a new movie out from
Disney yeah man but those Jewish people
what dude come on yeah I I like bro we
got because it wouldn't have gone very
well either way yeah we got a few
minutes into the show and he went right
off
shout out Danny Paul's truck with that
tweet that you nailed it I can't believe
the thing he's been talking about for
two months came up on the show
but right away all right everybody
thanks for hanging out smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends we do have a
behind the scenes uncensored view we
filmed them on the trip out here and
then probably storming off and uh we're
gonna put up I think we're gonna have it
up tomorrow
and um I think it's it might be going up
as cast Castle I'm not sure uh like an
overt real Vlog I guess just check
everything man it'll be on the website
you'll see it and we're gonna put it up
uh it is what it is and then we'll uh
we'll shout it out I suppose
um you can follow the show at timcast
IRL follow us on Instagram you can
follow me personally at timcast to the
people who stormed in to save the show
after the guest stormed off uh who wants
to shout their stuff out well good
firstly my gems are not demonic Milo I
see you out there I know you're
listening to the show still thank you
for putting your beads on my geometric
patterns over here no that was that was
Nick that was Nick thank you Nick for
doing that and uh yes we will talk about
fractals next time I see you Milo
um have fun love you guys see you bye
Hannah
uh I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com and occasionally
I suddenly appear in the guest chair uh
you can follow me on Instagram at Hannah
claire.be you can find me on other
platforms if you put the work in you
should follow Tim cast news on Twitter
it's the best and you get to hear from
all of our journalists including me uh
Chris Bertman Chris Carr Cassandra
Fairbanks it's really worth the follow
and yeah and you'll see me tomorrow not
yay don't worry guys I'll be there uh on
Tuesday a pop culture crisis with Mary
yes speaking of which you should go
subscribe to pop culture crisis on
YouTube we go live at 3 P.M every
weekday you're laughing at something Tim
someone sent me the video of what
happened and the look on my face when
yay gets up I'm like
[Laughter]
follow me on Instagram or Twitter at
maryarchived that's all thank you ghost
girl if you're looking for uh the news
of what actually happened today check
out youtube.com forward slash we are
change I did a story about Balenciaga on
my members area Luke uncensored.com I
talk about a lot of different weird
stuff on there check it out Lucan
sensor.com splurge
Steely a fan still a Milo fan surge.com
surge.com on Instagram Twitter I guess I
don't really use it I don't do the
bookings here you guys know what it is
tomorrow is going to be amazing yeah so
Michael already announced this but
Michael Mouse is going to be here and um
it's episode 666. this is hilarious
because before the show I was like you
guys are on episode 665 and they were
like oh and yeah he's like what does
that mean and then Nick was like one
less than 666 he was like Wow and I was
like and tomorrow it's Michael malice
and they were like he's a Jewish
Anarchist oh no he was like he's Jewish
I'm like no he's an anarchist no no no
no I said and then I'm like I don't know
he's like he's Jewish and and I I'm sure
Mal's is gonna come on and have like a
book's worth of intelligent things today
we're big fans Michael we're excited
you're gonna be coming yeah all right
everybody we'll see you all tomorrow
thanks for hanging out cheers y'all